une production du studio sf
bio sans filtre représenté par caisse
mille podcast où on parle ce qu'on veut
avec nos invités battent
le plein kiss me on le dit la semaine
passée ont lancé de nouveaux produits
les pièces pour les airs potes je suis
allé voir les design unique aux caisses
d'un pad c'est complètement incroyable
et dhl pour un beau ordinateur portable
donc si vous êtes tannés de briser vos
cellulaires boeuf veau argentan porte je
sais que mogi casser trop d'affaires
dans mon temps bref allez voir sur le
site qu'ils me tuent dit que le premier
chef 15 assurez vous d'utiliser un peu
trop sage chez nous que vous envoie puis
profiter de 15 % de rabais pour protéger
on a demandé des
appareils électroniques dispendieux
cette semaine c'était notre caste on
reçoit un invité de podcasts
exceptionnel laurent turcot qui
historiens qui vulgarisateur qui
quelqu'un de fascinant de passionna
quelqu'un qui est encore en fait on peut
partir sur n'importe quel sujet qui va
nous faire l'histoire vous nous
expliquer ce segment quelqu'un juste de
colmar facilement à discuter avec lui on
a parlé beaucoup des sports aujourd'hui
en fait th fait une vidéo où elle est
née sur l'histoire des sports que vous
pouvez aller voir qui va être en ligne
dès maintenant en fait sur la fin
l'histoire nous le dira que la chaîne de
la main donc enfin doublé aujourd'hui
sur les deux chaînes qui en parlait
justement beaucoup de sport réflexion
sur les jeux olympiques réflexion sur la
violence au soudan pendant leur enquête
où se on a parlé
mais frontières de la envie de repousser
constamment être conscient des limites
de la de l'humanité
qui justement autant de de résonance
dans le sport qui dans l'exploration
spatiale on a parlé aussi un peu de deux
d'animés japonais a en fait on n'est pas
un parti du tee shirt que le rapporte
aujourd'hui c'est celle du studio ghibli
qui des films comme contador qui sont
tournés plx de luxe alors
en fait ça nous apprend qu'il reçoit
lors à qui toujours à la hauteur et on
va continuer à bosser sur yes on va les
remercier les commanditaires 20 blessés
à la conversation manon pas insulter
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par terriens terriens cpa terrain
terriens pour les jours un du podcast
sans fil vous les connaissez c'est le
premier sponsor qu'on a eu en fait oui
oui et puis c'est une firme comptable
puis nous en fait c'est la firme
comptable avec qui on farci au studio
servent depuis le tout début de plus la
première fois qu'ils nous ont approchés
si devenus nos comptables donc pour elle
pour les les délais les entreprises les
petites et moyennes entreprises ils
viennent de lancer un nouveau podcast
qui s'appelle les économies qui est
enregistrée ici au studio sfr donne de
quoi il parle dans ce pack est ce le but
pas de casser est connu c'est de
démystifier tout ce qui touche à
l'argent c'est des fois ça peut être
compliqué mais le fai ont démystifié
donc c'est plus simple on parle
d'entrepreneuriat dans les finances
parle d'assurance vie dits mobily de la
bourse des banques et du côté légal des
affaires tout des choses que kim je
voulais que ce pack personnes en france
je pense que quand j'en avais besoin
puis parle aussi de certaines industries
comme industrie du jeu vidéo
l'informatique
l'humour et la banque de détail alors
juste avant nicholl nicholl nicholl
nicholl pièce l'école toutes les cotes
le podcast les échos noël ce que tu
apprends sur l'argent
absolument même s est passé peu juste en
fait sur l'argent ils reçoivent des
entrepreneurs aussi ont sué entre autres
michel grenier pour longtemps gérant de
mike ward en trop qui
un tout non je suis pas intéressant
comme podcast ne manquent les postes
créés ou le maire- single donc on vous
invite à aller voir leur podcast sur
leur chaîne youtube les échos nous il
n'a pas tout vous trouvez des podcasts
de retrouver les ai connus cliquez yes
le podcast est présenté par nos amis
chez mindscape qui continue à encourager
le sempé le podcast parce que vous
continuez à vous acheter des produits
même skate on reçoit beaucoup de
commentaires moi chaque fois que je
parle à quelqu'un d'un rhume me parle
pratiquement de mindscape parce que
parce que les gens l'achètent qui
adorent leur expérience le lendemain 4.0
le on en parle sans arrêt mais c'est
parce que c'est la meilleure technologie
de clipper sur le marché il ya une skin
save technologique vous empêche de vous
[ __ ] soit les couilles si vous vous
rasez les couilles ou ou boyle à la
barre de la moustache donne tout ce qui
fait sûrement dit qu'elle pense à la
reine moustache et le moose h le cc
siffredi hier phénomène skype si donc pu
imaginer de quoi millions là où ce
n'est pas parfaite paquet
4.0 tout ce que vous avez besoin la
dengue au lendemain mais aussi les
petits produits désodorisants pour base
et compagnie petit honneur il ya aussi
les boxeurs m'indiquer où les adore ces
gens me voient que sa préférée de
l'époque même en ce moment même je m'en
vais vous démontrer mais je le ferai pas
[Musique]
confortable il ya un petit shoot la
daille le parfum que ph porte ouais moi
ça c'est mon parfum je l'adopté je
pensais pas que j'arrête un gars qui
allait avoir un parfum mais chaque fois
que je sors mettant dans une situation
un peu plus huppé je me parfume un peu
avec le maintien puis honnêtement je
marche vous savez faire ça mais ça me
donne
un beau gosse de confiance ce projet on
a un code promo pour aux autres que le
sans filtre wingles pour 20% de rabais
et le shopping gratuit c'est pas un
petit rabais c'est énorme dans le fond -
% de rabais que ce chiffre est gratuit
fait procurez-vous s'appuie pour le
savoir deux comparses yann merci martin
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrête ça vole haut rang merci d'être là
c'est vers lui yes la première fois mais
la première et seule fois contre bruce a
fait 15 morts en une semaine deux ans
qu'on a sauvé le quasiment deux ans que
l'épisode sonne 15e vérifié hier parce
qu'il va demander lors me rendis à 175 à
peu près 70 ça fait quasiment deux ans
puis je me rappelle qu'un qu'on t'avait
reçus ont cherché des invités a invité
puis 2 m'avait écrit fait un check sur
la chaîne youtube l'histoire nous le
dira si un gars qui s'appelle laura
turco qui est derrière ça serait le fun
de l'inviter à ce moment là je pense
qu'avec comme 30 mais l'abonné 7h
hangzhou youtube à ce jour tu es rendu
au dessus 310000 plié quand compense
histoire tu es un peu entré dans le
monde
public comme tu nous disais que tu
espérais frères d'amener l'histoire dans
le domaine public puis comme de fait
c'est ce que s'est passé dans les
derniers mois est un peu aussi s'est il
ya différents facteurs qui expliquent
explosion de la chaîne le fait d'être
venu ici le fait d'être venu chez jay du
temple feb est allé à tout le monde en
parle sur le voie directe le le gain
d'abonnés en lien avec ces émissions
l'hôpital et cherche un public
complètement autre dans lequel tu
t'attendais pas mais la pandémie je
pense que son pour en parler peut-être
un jour au fait augmente énormément les
écoute en ligne autant sur les balados
que youtube puis avait des profs qui
m'écrivait pour me dire pour te faire
une vidéo là dessus la tulette reçus par
le studio puis pas rare que certains
jeunes maintenant me disait mon prof
à s'écouter de tes vidéos away laquelle
je sais pour
remarquez ça va
mais 10 puis le fait pas c'est là que tu
te rends compte que le public est très
éclaté aussi mais on a parlé beaucoup
j'ai parlé avec vous aussi comment tu
fais pour aller à lille plus de gens par
rapport à l'éclatement des plateformes
aussi ce que tu vas sur secteur qu'est
ce que tu piges essaie de faire des
trucs sur techtoc ça marche moyennement
bien je me suis dit toute façon je peux
pas tout faire parce que ça serait en
soi puis c'est je pense qu'il faut aussi
garder en tête que chaque plateforme au
otc ses forces et ses faiblesses puis
pour le genre de contenu que tu offres
secteur que ce peut être pas exactement
le la plateforme multi mais c'est vrai
puis d'autant plus que c'est des vidéos
que je fais qui sont assez longues 1
puis de plus en plus longue même parce
que j'ai c'est d'offrir des choses pour
les écoles je me dis si on a envie de
faire du 35 minutes ça va être du 35
minutes puis j'ai envie de faire une
vidéo 17 heures je vais en faire une de
cet art grand train de publier le
devance et on tente on te prie tous les
les épisodes avaient fait sur la
deuxième guerre mondiale deux amis en
main j'ai rassemblé en menant puis quand
même du bon contenu de cet or que sur
youtube vous dit ça a été très long à
faire parce que tu en es tu veux là
dessus c'est pour faire un secteur à la
tv je compte de la rai tv la télé excuse
moi je compte plus le nombre de
personnes qui aient serait sur ce projet
mais il y avait moins carl pépin call
qui écrit le script moi qui étais la
script édition de tout retravailler et
après ça mais j'étais venu là la vidéo
va sortir bientôt un jeu mais mon stock
je pars tout pire personne derrière
pearson aus ont personnellement les
rages personne derrière la caméra
personne pour me wade tu t'es trompé tel
mode se tromper de telle année donc je
sais pas comment ça se passe après ça
c'est moi qui dérogent c'est moi qui
découpe c'est moi qui monte c'est moi
qui mixe c'est cet âge bien honnêtement
je ne sais plus combien de temps j'ai
passé là dessus mais ça vaut la peine
parce que ça ça reste puis surtout sexy
ya des gens qui veulent en savoir plus
pis surtout c'est que c'est gratuit bae
systems et le but de faire société
mais je me coupe en disant qu' il ya eu
une grande tendance au début des années
2000 même avant ce qui est l université
populaire
c'est à dire tu avais des profs qui
disait tout ça c'est beau ce qu'on fait
nous autres dans les universités même
année faut toucher le public pis les
médias un domaine particulier ou est-ce
qu'il faut que tu rentres dans les codes
du punch vous qui clashe les autres se
sont dit on veut éduquer le monde d'une
manière très simple donc y aller dans
les villages y allait dans les
universités y allait dans les collèges
les écoles puis parlait de manière très
simple de choses complexes la
philosophie de l'histoire etc
puis avec les nouveaux médias tu dis
ouais ce qu'est devenue l'université
populaire est ce que justement ça serait
poste puis moi c'est une extension de
mon travail de professeur un peu mon
service à la collectivité que je fais
pour le plus grand nombre on le voit aux
autres beaucoup de ce fait on a pris un
petit tournant plus
scientifique et social et sociale aussi
ouest connaissait de recevoir des profs
d'université des charges de cours des
gens qui qui ont domaine rang précis
parce que je pense que l'addiction laver
avec rémi quirion le scientifique en
chef du québec qui me disait que le défi
c'était vraiment capable de prendre les
connaissances acquises à l'université
mais essayer de sortir contrairement à
l'idée que l'université un vase clos
depuis que tout le monde
l'information reste dense et dans ce
vase clos lot puis puis on le voit tirer
juste avec notre auditoire c'est les
podcasts qui génère le plus de réactions
sont ceux où esker on amène quelqu'un
qui est un expert dans un domaine le
treut précis mais qui est bon aussi à
vulgariser
cette chose là ce qui fait que à la fois
nous et nos auditeurs on apprend quelque
chose puis on se rend compte qu'il y
avait mieux à faire qu'on connaît pas
que qui font partie de la connaissance
générale humaine le trip que tu peux
comprendre si seul le grand défi vous le
faites très bien ici de donner la parole
à des gens qui sont des bons profs pour
la plupart millions pour l'auditoire ou
qui ont pas qui on peut la chance
d'aller dans les médias parce que c'est
très compliqué sur les médias y ont leur
personne connue ils vont très vite faut
que soigner notre de répondre dans les
5-6 art tout c'est après ce bain je peux
pas mais demain je pourrais rien on
savait trop tard c'est fini tu es plus
dans l'ain dans la loupe pis le fait de
permis des gens d'expliquer des choses
qu'on pense complexe vous qui au final
le sont pas puis la pandémie a forcé les
experts à ce deuil
d illuminer le faux communiqué disant
liaison puis
c'est pas tant qu'on les a laissés trop
parler que nous qui n'avons pas assez
parlé c'est nous qui n'avons pas assez
pris la place qui nous revenait et qu'on
considérait à être inutile parce que
c'est là dans la fonction de
vulgarisation tôt la notion de vulgaires
s'adresser au bon peuple uni pour
certains de ces inutiles ça dessert
tandis que moi je veux faire avancer mes
recherches mais moi dans matin ne peut
pas avancer des recherches sans offrir
de l'autre côté cette espèce de volonté
faire avancer l'esprit public mais il
faut que l'embarquement dans le bateau
avec toi sinon c'était deux soldats dans
sa barque en avant
les très intéressant c'est comme
question puis comme comme commentaire
sous-entendu faut que tu embarques les
gens avec toi puis il ya des codes dans
tous les médiums quel qu'il soit le cas
de youtube le code potes qui ait pas de
casse le code télé le code twitter et
facebook puis il y en a qui disent or
vous savez moi résumé en moins de deux
minutes ça ne m'intéresse pas mais tu le
fais déjà ils font déjà les profs
d'université quand tu es dans les cours
c'est exactement ce que tu fais tu
t'adresses à un auditoire qui est en
première année d'université qui est pas
nécessairement les connaissances pour
comprendre mais tu les amène avec nous
mais quand tu dis les prendre dans sa
barque c'est un peu ça c'est de se dire
oh les gens sont trop cons c'est
extrêmement condescendant alors que ce
que vous faite puisque plusieurs autres
fonds si tu te rends compte que des
choses qui sont le propre de
l'universite intéresse tout le monde
donc ça m'énerve vraiment pire beaucoup
de potes cas ce que vous faites ici au
sf home studio qui sont de plus en plus
diversifiée qui vont toucher des
domaines de plus en plus divers puis tu
dis oui mais ça va pas être meanstream
peut-être mais un public qui pour ces
faits rend de plus en plus les gens de
légende et couches comme à l'ordinaire
leurs champs d'intérêt pis il ya un
paquet pour ceci ou lieu de contenu pour
s'y attaquer ça devient spa pendaison
puis il ya
une bascule nous autres c'est un peu le
le pari qu'on avait fait en lançant le
podcast initialement d'après seul studio
c'était de se dire savent où l'on s'en
va vers l'ultra court l'ultra
fragmenté de cdd d huile de 15 secondes
et stories de ces affaires là puis même
même au delà de ceux des nouvelles dans
les journaux qui sont dans le fond 250
mo d entrevue radio des entrevues télé
qui sont ultra formaté qui comme tu dis
c'est un bon exercice de d'être capable
de rendre tout ce qu'on s'y met c'est
aussi une perte de nuances une perte de
profondeur dans les sujets puis je pense
qu'il ya eu vraiment une bascule dans
les dernières années puis pour favoriser
justement du contenu comme les podcasts
mais aussi comme ce que toi tu fais tes
du contenu ou est-ce qu'il faut quand
même c'est l'histoire nous le dira faut
tu t'assois tu l'écoutés titre faux
l'assimilent parce que parce que tu peux
pas mettre sur juste en background puis
dire j'ai appris sur telle affaire parce
que toro rien compris de ce qui s'est
passé le tir fait que je pense quel
contenu comme ceux qui recherchaient
mais qui est aussi le très pertinent a
vraiment pris une place beaucoup plus
grande dans la la sphère mehdi médias
sociaux retombe je trouve ça super
important mais c'est intéressant comme
notion parce que ce que tu viens de dire
c'est comme si on disait puis-je un peu
d'accord avec toi on se nourrit d'éclat
c'est à dire des petits tas passes
rapides des débouchés à manger on passe
à autre chose qui on veut goûter à tout
on veut pas nécessairement prendre un
groupe là pour en profiter longtemps
alors que c'est plutôt l'inversé convoi
puis j'ai envie de te dire tu avoir le
temps il y aurait une étude sociologique
historique à faire d'où sa part ce à
quel moment puis moi j'ai une intuition
l'intuition c'est que on a assisté
depuis lors une quinzaine vingtaine
d'années une pipolisation très très
forte de la télévision où il fallait
énormément de vedettes énormément
d'humoristes puis on s'est dit les les
choses un peu intellectuel
un peu trop comment dire relevé on va
les mettre de côté
on va se concentrer carrément sur le pur
divertissement
ce qui est énormément de bons éléments
puis je suis un grand consommateur de
télévision populaire jamais je
cracherais là dessus mais de la télé
réalité j'en consomme énormément bon
sens
qui nous
j'ai un grand fan au jour en france sur
le studio ghibli
ça s'en vient parce que
mon intuition c'est qu'à un moment donné
il ya comme une casse ou à ce que les
gens sont dit il manque quelque chose il
manque quelque chose qui t'a des
émissions qui poursuivait comme plus on
est de fous plus on lit à radio canada
qui est l'une des plus écoutées dans une
tranche horaire de l'après midi qui se
rend dans le complexe la manne et c'est
ok gagne mythologie pendant 30 minutes
qui ça marche c'est des gens ultra
compétent dans un style clair simple
sacré pleine carrière simon boulerice
par exemple qui est sorti de là qui fait
aujourd'hui une magnifique carrière un
grand auteur jeunesse je pense que vous
les gars vous êtes arrivé à un moment où
une nouvelle génération qui arrive qui
veut plus puis on leur a offert à
travers des modes cas ce podcast plus
méditative ce que j'entends par
méditatif c'est quand tu te nourris des
classes comme parfum petit feu
d'artifice qui a éclaté mais quand tu es
dans le plus long tout d'un coup ton
corps
s'habitue dit c'est quand on regarde les
vidéos se peut pas juste regarder 110
l'étendrons tu t'assois puis le fait
asseoir de te concentrer de te fermés au
monde je pense qu'on a besoin de ça la
même manière qu'on a besoin de lire un
livre va m'amener sans être plus longues
et sur internet pour voir une
notification pop et pour des il ya ce
qui vient d'arriver ah non les oeillères
hama n'est pas pour se couper du monde
mais pour se concentrer sur un élément
je pense que c'est ce qui motive aussi
le podcast mais la tournure comprends je
demande à recevoir plus des experts en
savoir plus exactement ce que tu désires
leur cd de l'opinion petit
divertissement il y en a déjà assez déjà
beaucoup de l'opinion tout le monde une
opinion surtout aujourd'hui de mon
exprime son opinion sur tout réseau
sociaux mais l'effet de l'objectivité de
la science il sait ce qu'il ce qui
manque en ce moment pendant vos des
conséquences et de la nourriture c'est
ça c'est que tu peux pas te nourrir de
crémage il faut les pignons c'est le
crémage que tu rajoutes mais c'est
injuste du crémage je fais non monsieur
carle imagine ce dit je vais t'offrir un
gâteau de noces qui veut juste avoir du
du crémage enfin c'est qu'un vite là
c'est sucré ses groupies ceux qui ont
jamais fait de crémage de gâteau vous
regardez le nombre de bars calade dalle
si tu marches que tu vas mourir
si petits fours une diversité mais on
serait fou de dire que tout se vaut je
pense qu'il ya des fruits des légumes
même amené dans le contenu puis les
fruits les légumes site et à sa manne et
l'esprit va dépérir pense que comme
société
j'aime j'aime ça quand il ya des
émissions comme plus on est de fous plus
on lit j'aime ce gamin et quand il ya
des émissions comme aujourd'hui
l'histoire qui marche énormément en ce
moment pis tant mieux ou est ce qu'on se
dit peut-être que ça va chercher un
moins grand public pendant le code les
deux quotidiens d'évoquer mais qui vont
aller trouver quand même des gens qui
ont besoin de cinq missions leur offre
pas l'oeil un problème ça peut servir un
plus grand non plus qu'on ne le croit
mais je pense aussi puis je pense qu'ils
étaient dans ces colonnes
idée du contenu qui parle à tout le
monde
ça parle finalement a pas grand monde
lui aussi souhaité ce scélérat c'est ce
que j'essaie de dire si mettons les
autres quand on le fait ça se faisait
pas beaucoup le racontez moi donc
comment vous avez commencé quand vous
êtes dit parce que vous avez parlé
quelques fois mais
ça faisait longtemps qu'on cherchait un
projet le cac n'était au secondaire on
voulait dominer le monde avec plusieurs
vidéos à manille se partager ça l'amusé
camion faisait on a fait on a eu trop
d'idées concrétiser jab le lendemain on
y passait mais
c'est vraiment c'est très court terme
puis
c'est le pph fait pas son double clé est
sortie des deux le puits c'était une
période où est ce que t on se parlait
encore beaucoup de route voyez un peu
moins ou du moins si on était plus les
belles tomates
puis
on met ce dont on se parlait souvent ce
n'est pas qu'à ce qu'on écoute ici mais
tout est elle pas de casser tout est à
la fois rappelons la dignité de ce puits
c'est comme devenu rapidement genre
d'intérêt commun qu'on avait un jour de
leurs deux passions thiam année je
passais juste moi qui ai fait
je prends pas de gaspillage in the past
examen même chose courtois podcast puis
quelques semaines après on sortait
premier épisode piste est comme ci
dessus est temps de l'appliquer mais
valve fait des tests qui on a appris
comment ça marche et l'enregistrement de
faire trop de casse les deux ensembles
seul qu'on a jetée parce qu'on était
près d'enregistrer rien
exemple est mauvais
écoute moi le premier vous allez voir la
bande annonce que j'ai fait j'ai pas
acheté la bonne affaire et là les gens
voient pas au mieux 3 trépied moi
j'avais acheté un pauvre comme ça que tu
devais tenir mais je ne pouvais pas
l'obtenir fait j'avais fait tenir la
caméra en équilibre mais le problème
c'est que faisait seulement c'est
qu'elles avançaient et reculaient
faut que ce soit faux vivendi j'avais
partie mon enregistreuse je me savais
pas comment ça marche et fait que le son
enregistré fixer la sonde le sens la
carrière c'est dégueu je fais comme hbo
d'après ce que j'ai fait ma première
vidéo mais chose le son est dégueu il ya
plein de gens qui écrivent après ça dans
la communauté pour des questions fait
prends ton pays plein de gens qui tide
apprécié le suivre sur groupe se fait
comment fonctionne-t-elle caméra comme
un hors jeu juste que tu dis lol
c'est le thé je suis loin d'être un sage
ou un expert le mais si j'ai un conseil
à donner mais tend à inspecter même pas
dire à des gens des buts et n va de rap
à péage début vingtaine c'est comment
ton enfant commence le stone idée
comment cela parce que c'est attend que
ce soit parfait sera jamais rien
commencé à chaque fois s'améliore encore
c'est juste que toi c'est la même chose
c'est on veut dans le système tu leur
dépit à chaque seshoka à force de faire
le montage d'été vidéo tous ces mets ton
qui est non là je vais reprendre la tête
parce que je sais qu'au montage ça va
être plus chiant que ça fait tout et
tout est mieux loti mais comme tu dis si
désolée c'est ce que les gens qui nous
écoutent qui veut le voir de quoi on
parle allez voir les premiers que des
hologrammes est une catastrophe qui même
les vidéos d un ennemi mon éclairage en
arrière et d'aigus on a l'impression que
c'est mort puis il ya des amis de ma
blonde qui fait les éclairages pour le
cirque du soleil comprenant vers amman m
10e rang je travaille pas en ce moment
c'est comme la pandémie voiture gêne t d
pour the way we puis moi comme expliqué
plus vous irez voir en arrière j'ai mis
une lumière qui orange et tout le
village était là puis après ça j'ai un
relais qui la même couleur faits qui
donnent l'impression que la lumière en
arrière bien se projeter sur nous qui
nous des coupes carrément sur l'image
c'est un petit détail mais qui en est
pas un bisou échangé sur du fine tuning
comme ça c'est vrai que quand
j'enregistre parce que ce que les gens
peut-être ça vous savent pas c'est que
manger un prompteur fait que tout est
écrit avec la joe qui est écrit sous
truc mes jokes mauvaise passe
mais ça donne beaucoup plus de de
sécurité parce que la technique c'est
très déstabilisant pis c'est quand tu
dis lance toi c'est parce que tout ça
c'est compliqué ses droits d'homme était
dans le domaine des habitués enregistré
quelqu'un qui lui écrit tu veux faire du
contenu
enregistré film et c'est complexe mais
en même temps tu dis pointons téléphone
enregistra leçon va être correct ce
qu'il faut c'est un trépied pas les
limites peux t'acheter un micro à 20
pièces sur le blog directement sur
l'entrée ton téléphone peut seulement
micro-cravate puissant vêtements je
saute le pas ce que tu peux rattraper
l'image en mettant quelque chose mais le
son ci est pourri la leçon c'est la
chose la plus importante dans ce genre
d'affaires c'est moi dès qu'un podcast
qui est même si le sujet m'intéresse
s'ils sont liés pas bon c'est sûr que je
n'écoute pas au complet c'est à dessein
que je fais exprès elle s'est par
exemple quelqu'un qui table je suis
désolé de ce qui nous en tant que j'ai
fait
mais c'est vrai c'est que c'est des
détails qu'il faut que tu as ténue il
faut se contrôler parce que toi même
comme audi stade dit qu'est ce que
j'écouterais
exigences réalité le fait de se monter
moi je me montre moi même puis ma blonde
a dit pas comment tu fais a dit moi je
voudrais me tuer je veux tuer mais tu
vois toutes tes défauts pitt et atb qui
je me souviens parce que j'avais pris
des cours de théâtre dans une autre vie
je pensais que si vous disiez que vous
aviez plein de projets - si le losc veut
devenir acteur un jour je raconterai ses
pistes à paris je faisais matin je
prenais des cours de théâtre j'avais un
tic puis plusieurs tic même pierre un
moment donné à chaque fois que je
faisais stick la tic de langage profiter
à taper dans les mains puis ème année
c'était
ok c'est bon j'avais envie de le tuer ça
m'a carrément coupé mon tic parce que
faut que tu es quelqu'un en arrière et
si vous avez quelqu'un vous êtes deux
faciles ouais mais tu vois on fait
longtemps qu'on trécu depuis par exemple
vous avez quelqu'un pour la mer c'est ce
que si on l'écouté c'est ce qu'ils sont
l'écouté on remarquait des affaires on
corrige récente en safari pour
possiblement qu'on s'améliore et même
année on fait d'ailleurs fait des
compromis ont fait des connaissances
c'est beaucoup de temps et pour ceux qui
commencent réécouter mais c'est sur ce
soir et gardez vous les premiers mois je
me réécouter systématiquement puis j'ai
remarqué des enfants je sais bien que
mal et à suivre des cours de diction à
j'ai fait une coupe des cours de diction
pour essayer d'améliorer ce et puis je
peux non mais c'est un bon truc s'est
articulé de faire des exercices avant de
parler jusque usine où l'on
entraînements les choses extrêmement
quelqu'un mais c'est parce que les gens
voient pas tout le travail que avant de
ce qui est fait ils pensent que l'on
pose la came here on pose le micro piles
et hugo puis que le sujet nous vient en
fait de manière holistique cas pas du
tout mais justement je voulais je lui ai
fait
partir de l'exemple du de la vidéo qu'on
a fait en sambre et les gens qui nous
écoutent en ce moment
la vidéo est en ligne c'est sûr au
moment où est ce que vous écoutez
donc une vidéo sur l'histoire du sport
pis je voudrais comprendre cet exemple
pour que tu nous expliques un peu
comment fêter recherche comment ce
travail parce que tu tout est un expert
de la france est un expert de la
révolution française n'a pas hésité sur
précisément le promeneur à paris au
xviiie siècle promeneurs à paris au
xviiie siècle des tétons teutons 18e
hewitt
pis c'est cet échec n'est pas un expert
l'histoire du sport le livre sur
l'histoire du sport il va des origines à
nos jours ce qui était publié en 2016
chez gallimard en fait ce que je t'ai
fait face d'une partie de mon chapitre
sur le xxème siècle où j'expliquais pour
ceux qui ont peu vu la vidéo comment on
est passé d'un monde désenchanté c'est à
dire un monde où la religion n'est plus
le moteur principal à une société où la
transcendance par le corps devient
fondamental ce que j'entends par
transcendance par le corps c'est comme
si on dit les gens croient plus à rien
croit plus à l'eau de la crau peu à
l'enfer au paradis ou quoi que ce soit à
la presse donc ils vont rejeter sur leur
corps à eux la fonction de transcendance
lier le devenir le plus grand que
manquent eux mêmes et donc de bâtir son
corps va devenir une nouvelle forme de
religion au 20e siècle et c'est pas pour
rien qu'on parle pour les grands
sportifs de dieux du stade c'est pas
pour rien qu'on parle pour le canadien
de montréal de la sainte flanelle c'est
pas pour rien qu'on utilise toutes ces
métaphore religieuse pour le sport ou
même pour le hockey pour décrire ce
qu'on fait parce que c'est une manière
de se construire de contrôler notre
corps médias les plus grands parce que
50 des valeurs qui sont celles de notre
société la valeur d'efficacité bien sûr
la valeur aussi de santé la valeur
médicale c'est quand je le dis la valeur
d'efficacité sont on en parle beaucoup
dans la capsule les valeurs qui sont
celles du capitalisme sont exactement
les mêmes valeurs qui sont promus dans
le sport le meilleur gagne celui qui
perd plaire à n'en plus finir mais c'est
toujours celui qui est le plus efficace
qui va battre le plus de records
possibles puis si tu regardes les grands
pdg se font un grand plaisir de montrer
le sport les sports qu'ils font ils font
de la course 1 est une course contre eux
mêmes veulent vraiment les mêmes de
lacombe avec françois lambert leur
tournoi la mecque françois lambert
je pense que septième épisode sans
filtre il nous disait que hier
participer à une compétition c'était de
fitte est si haut puis c'est juste des
six aux deux compagnies qui font des
compétitions puis comme huit épreuves
puis un clonage un classement deux
points pour des épreuves physiques
évidemment le titre vélo de la natation
ces choses là pour trouver ceux qui le
signent au le plus futuriste
intéressante parce que tu vois que tu es
carrément dans le domaine selon lequel
l'activité sportive mais plus encore
l'entraînement si pas juste du sport
c'est plus que ceux de la même manière
quand je regarde les olympiques quand tu
regardes le roux quand tu regardes la
coupe du monde le acquis c'est pas juste
du sport garde la sphère de kotka niemi
qu'on a vu on est humain voyons s'est
rendu en finale la coupe stanley ce gala
était aimée à montréal puis est allé
signer en insultant parce qu'ils ont
rajouté une prime de 20 pièces puis le
tout le monde a dit est juste business 1
mais nous on veut pas y croire parce que
les canadiens s'est tatoué sur le cac
c'est maurice richard t c'est la grande
époque la sainte flanelle c'est patrick
roy si tout ceci c'est intimement liée à
l'histoire des francophones au québec
qui ont dit tu peux pas ainsi la manière
là sur le canadien disant moi ce que je
veux c'est large alors que
c'est complètement son drap le sport
d'une espèce de moralité p-dg de
transcendance qui rien qui aurait rien à
voir avec la société alors que c'est ben
laden ne support pillent le sport ces
pilleurs le spot point de vue de
l'athlète l'athlète qui va aux
olympiques le nageur le coureur fait
passer pour le cash il fait cela ça
c'est intéressant quand même pas ce
qu'est ce qui fait vraiment ce pour le
cash oui ou non oui d'une certaine
manière parce qu'il faut qu'il soit
rentable un athlète que pas de
commanditaire il n'a pas les hors la
plupart sont pas rentables oui la
plupart sont pas rentables ils font
quand même oui s'auto raison mais à un
moment donné si tu veux avoir une
carrière dans la douche rés faut que tu
sois capable financièrement puisses te
dis ça parce que il ya quelques années
il y avait des grandes critiques aux
olympiques pour dire le canada s'apprête
bon sens on gagne aucune médaille plus
il y avait institué un programme
gouvernemental qui s'appelle pour le
podium si je me souviens bien qu'ils
avaient financé les athlètes les
athlètes gagnait de l'argent si gagné
deux médailles
c'est mieux que ça peut faire une
différence surtout techniquement c'est
des athlètes amateurs j'étais
techniquement un souci est l'eau tout
d'un coup tu as vu le nombre de
médailles augmenter celle où tu te rends
compte que finalement l'argent une
grande prise sur le sport encore une
fois c'est quand tu dis j'ai dit que les
athlètes amateurs sont aux olympiques ce
parce que c'est tout les olympiques qui
sont un peu mal fou dessus pierre de
coubertin quand il refonde les jeux
olympiques à la fin du 19e siècle lui il
dit je veux juste des athlètes amateurs
parce que tu as des athlètes
professionnels qui font ça pour le cash
pour lui les professionnels qui font ça
pour le cash c'est vulgaire lui ce qu'il
veut c'est des athlètes naturel pour
entraîner qui font passer pour le cash
de manière désintéressée et toute
l'histoire des olympiques ce avec une
pension entre l'amateurisme et les
professionnels c'est pour ça que les
athlètes de la ligue nationale de hockey
ont mis autant de temps à aller aux
olympiques ont dit mais comment ça se
fait au canada nous aurait planté
pendant les années 50 les années 70
quand tu regardes aux olympiques d'hiver
tu fais comment ça se fait qu'on est
pourri ou à l'épée quoique et parce que
les athlètes professionnels ne peuvent
pas y aller il a 76 on le voit peu à peu
se résoudre dans les années 80 où on va
supposer qu'ils gagnent c'est de
l'argent point final comme par hasard
les années 80 c'est la montée en
puissance du néolibéralisme avec
margaret thatcher avec ronald reagan où
le marché est tout puissant à la fin des
années 80 c'est la chute de l'union
soviétique
la chute justement du rideau de fer donc
là le gain du capitalisme assumer fou le
sport devient le modèle type de la
rentabilité sportives et de la
rentabilité économique
et c'est là que tu vois que le sport est
un miroir complet de la société c'est
pour ça quand certains ne font pas ça
pour l'argent tu as raison tu as raison
parce qu'il y en a qui font ça parce qu'
il aime ça puis d'autant plus passer
leur carrière sportive
rentable disons il continue en faire
pour l'amour du sport quand même des
athlètes qui vont dans une petit club
minuscule qui parce qu'ils veulent
continuer à jouer parce que pour eux
c'est un acte de définition c'est de la
transcendance la transcendance
spirituelle même j'ai envie de te dire
mais faut que tu vives font souvent
c'est ben beau vives de ton avoir dix
fois la 28 ans mais 28 ans là ça
commence déjà presque est vieux pour un
joueur acquis auprès sports et ea quand
tu dit chris chelios a 35 ans tu disais
et où
il est sur la fin mais il continue
jusqu'à 40 ans il ya romeria gars même
chose
non mais c'est le petit voit que une
tension dans le sport puis la même
tension qu'on retrouve nous dans notre
société
puis l'avantagé jeux olympiques c'est
que tu vois des athlètes qui partent un
peu de rien pour devenir des super stars
et moi celle qui m'a le plus
impressionné aux vernis olympique ces
mots de charron aux haltérophiles il y
avait plein de reportages ou suivait les
athlètes pendant la coved elle à
rimouski dans son garage seul à lever
des poids en visioconférence avec son
entraîneur qui est ailleurs si c'est
rocky balboa d'un rock 5 qui
s'entraînent dans le froid parce que
je veux voir ce qu'on prend pied au même
moment tu avais l'histoire de logan
mailloux qui est arrivé jeudi à y
pense quand les canadiens puis mots de
charron vianden qu'il faut qu'on admire
beaucoup plus convaincre ses septs en
cela qu'il est très intéressante dans le
sport mais qui par simple nom il noir et
blanche puis la question d'hier la
question des olympiques structure ou si
c'est de se dire tellement d'argent qui
est générée par les olympiques puis y en
a tellement peu qui revient aux athlètes
les sur tous les sports amateurs les
tiges et
on se pose la question
c'est une vraiment louable les
olympiques ticket ce qu'on fait avec ça
alors que c'est le rêve d'une vie de
toutes ces athlètes l'homme et qu'au
final n'a pas vraiment envie
d'encourager en fait c'est les grandes
tensions qui existent depuis longtemps
de ces albert jacquard grand philosophe
qui avait écrit un livre pour dire il
faut arrêter les olympiques parce que
pour lui c'est une destruction complète
puis quand tu regardes les anciens sites
olympiques ce qui en reste jalousie puis
même morale nous tu regardes le stade
olympique on le paye et pendant 40 ans
ce qui est assez symbolique c'est que
pour payer le stade olympique à montréal
on a mis une taxe sur les produits du
tabac pour payer le stade le sport on a
taxé les fumeurs qui se tuent viol est
une métaphore magnifique de notre
société mais sais tu dis est ce que ça
vaut la peine les olympiques storgaard
tokyo il ya beaucoup de gens à tokyo
derniers jeux olympiques pendant la
pandémie qui devait se tenir en 2020 qui
ont été tenus en 2021 puis disait on
veut pas les tenir
dit non mais vous avez signé c'est là
que tu vois l'espèce de
conserver très conservatisme put1 du cio
qui dessert le sport plus qu'autre chose
c'est le petit disque il faudrait pas
casser ce modèle up il ya des gens qui
l'ont cassé puis un ou des organisations
qui le cassis et la fifa la fédération
internationale de football association
qui fait la coupe du monde ce rendez
compte que leur sport se développe est
mal ou pas comme il voulait pendant les
olympiques donc sont dit on va créer
notre compétition et ils l'ont intercalé
entre les olympiques et à les olympiques
deux ans après la coupe du monde les
olympiques d'été revient sur une seule
voie la coupe du monde de soccer de
fautes balle qui extrêmement suivie que
pas du tout d'amateurisme là dedans ils
ont assumé dès le début nous autres
c'est pour faire de l'argent point final
d'attirer aussi corrompu que ce seuil au
delà ce ces sols mais ce qui est affreux
là dedans c'est l'athlète lui y'a pas
demander avis lui tout ce qu'il veut
c'est faire son sport mais subit les
formes d'oppression
que sont les célèbres
ce qui est exactement dans la même chose
que dans la société le pauvre
travailleurs qui gagnent sont douze
pièces dollars wall mart lui tout ce
qu'il veut c'est finir ses fins de mois
mais subit les formes d'oppression du
capitalisme qui ne lui permet pas de se
libérer fait une métaphore magnifique
dans l'espace pour ça que les gens qui
disent n'importe quoi le sport ça sert à
rien ce fait un serpent rien de ça fait
des carrières sa garde en santé ça donne
un horizon d'attenté ça permet de sortir
les jeunes de la rue mais il ya des
travers à travers si les adp qui y ont
le meilleur le branding plus forte
qu'elle compétition parce que justement
c'est tellement leurs autres deux
olympiques puis le rêve olympique théo
pas du rêve en épée plus haut plus vite
plus fort c'est cesser d'aider qu'il est
les athlètes ont cinq six ans que ton
rêve à lausanne un pic le tpiy cc6 comme
implanté dans la tête de n'importe quel
jeune sportif c'est atteint des sommes
impayées pas rien d'autre dans le monde
entier ou est-ce que si tu y participes
te faire intacts tous
systématiquement ses les olympiques
aussitôt que tu es sélectionné pour
aller aux olympiques fait tatouer les
fait tatouer littéralement legault oui
de l'événement sur ton corps est
impressionnant cette fonction de
tatouages parce que tu sais on peut le
voir de manière très symbolique
individuel où on peut le voir de manière
inversée c'est comme sait les vaches à
qui on met un numéro carrément on brûle
le numéro sur la peau pour dire tu es à
nous maintenant il y en a qui s'attaque
aux olympiques t on dira jamais assez à
sotchi avec les lois anti homosexuels
qui avait été passé par la russie de
vladimir poutine certains athlètes
avaient voulu manifester avec le drapeau
de la fierté et on leur avait dit s'ils
voulaient manifester opposant ns a fait
un spot à 60 kilomètres loin du village
olympique puis vous le faites là bas
parce que les olympiques ne peuvent pas
être politique encore une fois c'est un
non sens comment le sport ne peut pas
être politique alors que même pierre de
coubertin v10 les olympiques c'est un
moyen pour les nations de se faire la
guerre sans faire de mort
fecteau c'est complètement tin oo mais
qui s'est très faux cul de la part des
dirigeants de croire que c'est à
politique le sport
c'est seulement ce paradoxe parce que
l'athlète lui et le titre que toute sa
vie s'est entraînée par les olympiques
dans l'épique soit en chinois russie il
s'en fout le camp ce qu'il veut c'est
parti d'un pic pis l'élève la plus la
grande majorité du monotype il les
polémiques puis les controverses puis la
corruption derrière tout ça
c'est pas son problème dans ce sens que
le rêve en faisant foi est tellement
fort que ce qui prime sur tout pis
justement les listes des cio est mort de
rire parce qu'il ya des athlètes les
merdes athlètes au monde qu'ils sont
prêts à venir bénévolement dans leurs
événements commandités à fond aux autres
font la grosse piastres donne rien puis
juste à cause il dirait quand même qu'il
redonne l'argent fédération un matin par
exemple des pays qui ont moins d'argent
pour le développement du sport chez les
jeunes saussez leur version officielle
tech centre de la
page sont tellement habile à
créer ses rêves le que justement c'est
comme n'importe qui les brigades
athlètes c'est l'ultime but pour
l'athlète en retour financièrement pas
grand chose financièrement progression
de choses tu as raison parce que la
majorité gagne pas de médaille la
majorité vont pas avoir de contrat mais
y'en a qui se disent ici si joannie
rochette qui gagne une médaille quand
même vécu toute une histoire après
sylvie bernier aussi car beaucoup
capitalisé la suite certains athlètes
qui dans leur pays une fois la médaille
gagnée peuvent après se capitaliser en
devenant en allant dans les médias en
étant analyse sportif il y en a très peu
maintenant allez vous allez pas que les
athlètes olympiques qui mettons gang une
médaille parce que j'en connais
personnellement puis le pire qui volent
leur arrivée m financièrement c'est
d'arriver enfin leur carrière à zéro
c'est parce que parce qu'ils vont avoir
dépensé beaucoup pour se déplacer les
clients entraînements ces choses là qui
sont pas payés par les fédérations qui
sont payés par leur poche sauf que
d'annexion sur l'équipe nationale tant
est qu'ils font qui ont une commandite
de ce côté là pour un maillot de bain
hong kong comme anti douleur pour des
souliers ils vont arriver à 0,6 ou dans
le positif mais ça sera jamais salaires
faramineux le type pour les sports comme
sinon ça sera pas des salaires
faramineux tu as raison de le dire puis
vous avez raison de dire aussi que le
cio est un peu crampes et en se
remplissant les poches
sur le dos des athlètes puis encore une
fois on peut faire la métaphore c'est
des gens qui travaillent par exemple
prenons une entreprise au hasard wal
mart ou maso un peu tout ce qu'ils
veulent c'est arriver à leurs fins à la
fin de mois pour payer pour que leur
enfant est de la nourriture sur la table
qui savent très bien que la pluie
pratique d'amazon wal mart sont ignobles
mais ils se disent faut que je travaille
une fois je trouve c'est mieux que rien
kim et c'est loctudy dans quelle mesure
peut-on [ __ ] le feu à tout pour
recommencer à zéro
dans la société comme dans le sport
c'est un peu la même chose si tu dis on
crée nos propres eaux limpides et bonne
chance la même manière dit i'm going up
de grid puis je vais plus travailler
j'ai donné un ermite bonne chance mais
comment tu fais pour changer comment tu
fais pour faute un coup à saab s'est
loupé tu vois que pour qui on vote nous
pour nos gouvernements puis c'est le
gouvernement qui nous représente 6
feixes nos gouvernements sont pas
capables de nous présenter efficacement
si justin trudeau dispo pour les
prochains olympiques on n'envoie pas
d'athlètes s'il n'ya pas telle ou telle
loi qui changent pas puis si on se met
pas en gagne pour le faire se passera
pas mais ça c'est fait dernièrement mais
dernièrement il ya eu des boycotts c'est
en 1980 moscou en 84 à los angeles ya eu
des boycotts à quoi ça menait à rien
premièrement parce que tu es tu aimes
dans une opposition urss uso ce qui
était complètement différent aujourd'hui
était dans une position qui serait on
est dans une forme d'oppression de
l'athlète ou d'aliénation de l'athlète
ou d'aliénation du citoyen du
travailleur avec un seul objet pas du
tout de réponse à ça ou ma fonction
c'est pas ça c'est d'essayer de le
comprendre puis de de révéler ces
mécanismes blanc puis de montrer que le
sport que l'on regarde serbie si je te
dis que la culture pop j'en suis un
grand fan de sport ch un fan fini le
petit 1 des clubs que j'adore ce machin
être un grand fan de foot en france je
regarde le paris saint germain puis tout
le monde me dit c'est ça depuis qu'ils
ont été achetés par les qatari je vais
non moi c'est à l'époque où y était
que je les suivais mes temps j'adore le
pg mais quand tu regardes qui se sont
acheté messi neymar de la rumeur on a
les meilleurs joueurs on a aussi me bat
p diddy belle offre je vais pas dans mes
mails et les gaules 28 de bon sens c'est
comme avant là le plafond salarial ou
acquis les red wings acheter les
meilleurs joueurs tu peux rentrer tout
le monde fait à quoi ça sert c'est une
des fonctions qui fait que le sport a
émergé au 19e siècle c'est qu'ils se
sont dit la savate mêmes règles pour
tout le monde
l'aristocrate va pas jouer vingt coups
avant le goût du peuple parce peaux
normales et que ça va être tout le monde
en même temps tout le monde les mêmes
règles puis peut-être qu'on est rendus
là maintenant que voudrait rebattre les
cartes pour dire tout le monde arrive de
jouer avec les mêmes cartes les mêmes
voitures les mêmes ballon les mêmes
choses sur les mêmes bases pour tout le
monde qui datent site puis on essaie de
le faire notamment avec le dopage le
dopage la ccl un des grands problèmes du
sport qu'on n'arrive pas à juguler se
regarde la russie se sont fait pogner qu
est-ce qu dernier 1 1 p campbell oeuvre
vous allez commissionné lation de la
russie le tout le monde est alors
l'athlète russe noah a été dire
l'athlète russe à la télé dit l'athlète
du roct c'est très drôle le roc rest of
canada
de quoi méditer si on n'est pas capable
de prendre acte de certaines décisions
ignoble qui sont dans le sport on a un
problème mais encore une fois si ça
revient ce que je sais c'est la
transcendance tellement vite se projeter
notez-le pied côte quand je regarde des
athlètes qui gagne je braille oui c'est
ça
l'amplificateur d'émotion par excellence
est un concentré d un etat kamouraska
cet été puis ont regardé les olympiques
chez des amis qui avaient un écran géant
granby
ont regardé le saut en hauteur plus son
auteur vous avez peut-être vu avec
l'italien puis locataires qui sont
arrivés kif kif cette séquence où les
deux sont avec larbi de piles arbitres
leur dîme on peut continuer si vous
voulez puis l'un 1 des 2 10 mais là si
on arrête là ont une médaille et deux
oui j'ai fait oui puis le regard qui se
tirent les deux si je te dis j'en ai des
frissons encore je raconte des faits ben
si ça c'est sûr le sport c'est époux que
j'ai dormi quand qu'on le voudrait coûte
le prochain qu'on le regarde si c'est ce
qu'on voit c'est avant de voir la
business avant de voir tout ce qu'on
voit c'est pire on voit les dépassements
humain et on voit la persévérance ligne
steam on voit tout ce pays qu'il
l'athlète aussi c'est ce qui ce qu'ils
voient aucun qu'il fait dans sa dans son
parcours 6 po
ici pour tout l'est justement la
politique autour du passé juste une
espèce de quête spirituelle de
dépassement de soi tous les teams de
réseaux céline tu me disais c'est le
vecteur démocratique par excellence
parti de rien il s'est rendu là c'est
comme notre société a choisi d'embarquer
de rien sauf des domaines rice c'est
pour ça que c'est magnifique le sport
parce que ça ça vaut chercher en nous
des valeurs qu'on a déjà intégré dans
notre société ça le catalyse à un tel
point que c'est émotif c'est du braille
écoute les canadiennes au soccer qui n'a
pas brailler ou exulté en regardant les
filles stéphanie labbé qui arrête tout
les pénaltys fumée merci bravo le puits
qui servent de sol et politique c'est
pour jouer sur la grille pour national
en même temps c'est l'équipe canadienne
de soccer avec la défenseure qui est
québécoise puis beaucoup qui ceux qui
viennent d'un peu partout au canada de
regarder on est capable de construire
quelque chose ensemble qui te d'un autre
côté des gens qui disent bella ce serait
le temps qu'on a une équipe québec parce
que gros ce qui nous intéresse c'est
surtout les québécois tu regardes ça
c'est vrai tu regardes radio can quand
ils font les jeux olympiques switch à
siby si ce fait et on n'est pas dans le
même pays on n'en parle même pas des
même sort jamais lampy ce regard-là la
couverture aux états unis en france en
allemagne tu fais et c'est paul mêmes
jeux olympiques on prend tout une petite
impression mais moi je trouve que
le sport c'est un meilleur moteur
narratif que pratiquement n'importe quoi
dans dans notre société parce que les
histoires se racontent d'elle-même puis
on dirait que des fois il ya des moments
je reviens je reviens souvent sommet les
en 2008 les olympiques de michael phelps
tu aurais fait un film
qui se passe demain c'est moi qui le
monde sera du cinéma le montre allociné
vous aurait dit non genre si c'est bon
c'est bien trop timorés cheveux ça je
peux pas et à chaque course de ses huit
médailles dont il ya quelque chose de
complètement fou qui se passe il s'est
piqué puis moi évidemment je connaissais
plus que la moyenne des ours le soin que
sauf que
les les commentateurs surtout à
nbc était vraiment bon pour
raconter chacun des chacune des
histoires chacune des médailles chacun
des records du monde chaque chose il y
avait un montage qui était faite
développe quatre ans qui avait perdu
contre ian thorpe y de velotte 3-1 au
champion du monde qui a battu deux
records du monde plaît à chaque fois y
avait quelque chose de cette histoire là
encore le encore aujourd'hui c'est comme
trop beau pour être dans la réalité le
tir mais c'est quelque chose s'est passé
pour vrai nom mais c'est beau la piscine
lancé c'est eux deux grands moments
selon moi aux inspecteurs la piscine pis
être laissées ça c'est vraiment le coeur
des olympiques mais bien honnêtement
moche plus infâmes
le 100 mètres hook andré degrâce et en
tout 200 points rouges
je lis beaucoup
[Musique]
si le xv aux-in ça vient de notre
histoire personnelle c'est moi ça a été
ben johnson malheureusement qui rentre
et qu'il n'avait qu'une dit mon père
c'était tout un petit peu trop avant d'y
aller parce qu'ils l'étaient au sein ou
en 96 quant aux 4 x 100 m bruny surin et
donovan bailey et les deux autres dont
j'oublie les noms ont battu les
américains sur leurs terres ou 4 x 100 m
écoute on en revenait pas pilote voici
un moment de communion aussi avec les
gens avec qui tu étais qui ont un parent
est un grand fan de sport d'autant plus
qu'en 76 à montréal il y avait une unité
mobile il faisait sa thèse de doctorat
puis évaluer l'écart des athlètes fait
qu'ils étaient allés à montréal avec une
unité pour évaluer quels types comment
se développer les différents cas selon
les sports puis almeida et qu'on lui a
données pour se rappeler qu'ils avaient
été présents jeux olympiques fait pour
moi ont regardé les olympiques avec mon
père ça allait de soi je les fais avec
mes enfants c'est la même chose tu vois
que tu transmettre ce qu'on appelle la
reproduction sociale se reproduit le
modèle qu'on te donne aux autres petits
c'était tellement un vecteur d'émotions
fortes petit c'est en parle de michael
phelps c'est intéressant ce que tu dis
la construction d'une narratif parce que
c'est vraiment se situe mais les
olympiques sans personne qui explique
ces comme qu'on avait leurs acquis sans
commentateurs sans rire tu fais quand
même où tu connaisse vraiment sûr pour
être capable d'apprécier ce que tu vois
qu'ils sont bons selon les commandes
alors l'homme et surtout à la radio mais
gouailleur quand tu l'entends tu fait
les yeux du monde leur faune c'est de
couper la télé il met la radio parce que
même quand il se passe rien radio
attention
radio n'ont pas le choix de vraiment ils
peuvent pas laisser genre de l'ambiguïté
l'image par avance
exact exact
ça m'a fait penser que c'est en tout cas
dessus quand il parlait du relais des
brunes sur un lit c'est fou le
patriotisme que les olympiques qui fait
sur gmp celle monde mais un lieu jeu
aucun moment dans la vie compte aussi
fiers de notre pays dans le drapeau de
nous en 96 c'est un an après le
référendum c'est ce qui est
impressionnant
les gens qui étaient pour le pays un an
après brandissaient le drapeau canadien
joe de gaillon de gagner c'est ce qui
vous voyez les mois à plus d'un jour le
jour je suis plutôt souverainiste le
tpiy mais n'empêche qu'il médailles
canadiennes comme yes médaille
canadienne seuil et comique québécois
est encore mieux
même dans la vie jeudi le ticket de soi
de l'ontario ou de berlin jeudi j'ai je
t'apprécie judo mais sans le classement
aussi pour vga ou détestent mais
c'est comme si c'est comme notre gang
compte 23 km c'est fou ce que ça c'est
facile c'est ça c'est la guerre
carrément on recrée les conditions de la
guerre si facile l'ennemi c'est l'autre
pourquoi parce que c'est l'autre parce
qu'on l'aiment pas parce qu'on veut
gagner parce que pas bonne couleur mais
tout ça c'est un peu artificielle une
certaine manière parce que c'est aussi
un combat individuel c'est au décathlon
vous avez sans doute suivi le décathlon
avec des miennes voyage li son nom de
famille qui a gagné le des questions tu
le voyais ce fait il est tellement
solide qui faisait tout le canada est
derrière toi en fait ça fait à peu près
juste deux semaines qu'on connaît mais
mais on est derrière
mais mais tu le regardes est
impressionnante sur le dépassement de
soi comme tu disais toujours à laquelle
impressionnant puis ça donne un modèle
est capable d'aller plus loin que ce qui
est déjà allé vite fait ok si lui peut
le faire je peux le faire à mon échelle
lafarge peut ramener ça à des amis son
héros sportif piquer les olympiques ce
tt à fait ça m'a donné le goût de me
lever
kidd était de bouger une tirade de quoi
juste comme de faire parce que c'est
tellement des modèles de persévérance et
de travail acharné que ça ça t'inspire
ces valeurs je ne veux pas noté fait que
c'est oui après ce seuil en or se
verront leur sujet les boutiques on
parlait de plus ces pourparlers qu'est
ce qui motive quelqu'un à courir des
ultramarathons creux des marathons à
s'entraîner autant on en parle quand tu
le fais pas non plus pour être meilleur
au monde parce que te ramène les romans
de pelleteuses et la plupart des gens
qui font ce qu'ils font les redmen du
mont tremblant jeu de sons sont à niveau
sont capables de le faire mais sont pas
au niveau compétition peña noter qu'il
ya cinq personnes dans le peloton pro
qui peuvent gagner c'est ça le reste des
jeux pas 2500 personnes qui participent
le monde qui font se sont pas drivée par
le fait grogner
contre avait parcouru un type c c'est
juste nos faire de dépassement de soi
d'atteindre l'objectif de
2,2 de faire mieux devant lui c'est la
même manière que quand tu travailles une
année et être vendus par exemple 40
chars l'année suivante soit 145
l'automne d'après 50 vectis est une
métaphore c'est une métaphore tellement
puis puis le dépassement de soi oui même
si c'est en anglais 10 mg buried que je
trouve très beau coup plus book incarner
un carnet s'exerce à rentrer dans ta
jamais un beau reid s'est dit aussi que
c'est comme ton corps en corporellement
spo bien dit métier c'est un peu cette
idée là ton corps devient la
représentation des valeurs de la société
puis le sport c'est l'incarnation de ça
tu deviens dans le sport ce que les
valeurs de 10 de fer pitt arrive à le
faire un niveau individuel que tu
contrôles c'est ça le grand avantage du
sport autant dans ta job les critères de
performance de sont imposés parfois mais
dans le sport c'est toi qui te les
impose donc tu dis tabarouette je vais
me battre puis au souvent ça l'idée de
jeu faire mieux que ce que j'ai fait
puis quand tu vois que tu descends tu
fais au qu'est ce qui se passe bel
enduit
vous êtes plus jeune que moi moi je suis
dans la pente un peu plus descendante où
je fais plus les temps que je faisais je
peux aussi bon que je faisais là pour
moi une de mes grandes forces au soccer
c'était je courais tout le temps tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps tout
le temps maintenant je me dis ok là
maintenant il faut croiser les jambes
aux techniques plus fort mais qui
courent moins c'est correct alors que
dans le sport c'est non plus vite plus
haut plus fort comme des olympiques mais
ça marche post idée là dans l'ordinaire
du sport mais ce que je dors dans leurs
deux stars du sport du corps faut qu'à
un moment donné tu acceptes de décélérer
lycée korek petit la même manière faut
que tu acceptes dans ta vie quotidienne
d'en faire moins de potes tout un fugace
de photos postées sur instagram fortis
ne serait rien aujourd'hui c'est correct
fiq dans le sport comme dans la société
ça permet de réorienter des priorités
je vais avancer une théorie que je
vienne que avancés avec vous en temps
réel est ce que
tu sais danser dans les sports de
cotonou mais mettons de de sport de
l'ultramarathon pis de iron man excluant
le volet pro c'est excluons les gens qui
font ce de façon professionnelle depuis
depuis le début vingtaine qu'ils sont à
leur pépite soit exclue en ce monde là
je vais me prendre moi comme exemple
pour illustrer la théorie que je vais
avancer moi quand j'ai fini ma quête de
notation
tlj vingt six fait qu il m'en restait un
peu encore mettons d'amélioration mais
plus tant que cela serait dans pente
descendante léger 30 puis mon pays qui
serait derrière mon âme est on prêt
sauf que qu'un chèque quand je suis
revenue d'occupation double donc après
ma carrière et à l'occupation des halls
survenue plus logique j'ai recommencé à
manger un petit peu mais rapidement j'ai
vu je retournerai jamais où est ce que
je t'ai pis j'ai commencé la course à
pied pile à la course à pied j'ai vu que
est en est que j'en avais jamais fait
avant je m'améliorais puis que même si
j'ai vieilli
étant donné que c'est un sport qui est
comme plus de 8 kilomètres plus tu
t'améliores pitié je suis loin d'être
élite fait ma pente d'amélioration je
peux contient mais le vrai problème en
jeu des banques j'avais 50 ans la
perceuse juste à faire de la course à
pied fait que ça me permet de
m'améliorer et ce qu'il répond un peu
dessus dans le désir de commencer parce
que là on voit mettons loges des gens
qui font des ultramarathons des ultra
trail redmen l'était le monde pense aux
jeunes on voit beaucoup de monde 2,5 de
plus de 50 ans qui qui passent leur
dimanche complet à faire des longues
sorties en vélo pour aller faire 300
kilomètres juste pour faire des arrêts
de même type à ce que au final il ya
encore un potentiel d'amélioration dans
ce sport là parce que à moins qu'on en
ait fait vraiment vraiment beaucoup de
façon pro quand tu étais plus jeune tu
peux t'améliorer longtemps parce que
c'est juste de développer ta machine
rouge ça donne un horizon d'attenté un
horizon de mieux un potentiel
d'amélioration de dire que t'es pas sur
la pente descendante exact ça c'est
vraiment la peur parce que c'est drôle
j'ai en train de travailler sur
l'histoire la crise la quarantaine moi
je suis [ __ ]
puis c'est vraiment l'idée puis j'ai
réfléchi beaucoup à ça en ce moment puis
ça recoupe ce que tu viens de dire la
crise la quarantaine c'est le moment où
on choisit notre vie se refait les choix
que tu avais fait en disant si tu ce que
je veux est-ce que c'est vraiment petit
et quand tu dis moi j'ai fait de la
natation toute ma vie j'ai recommencé à
faire la course à pied puis l'autre sur
voit un potentiel de réalisation du
froid qui peut s'étendre dans la longue
durée
tu te blesses
mais solide moi je me suis blessé en
courant là j'ai beaucoup de difficulté à
courir maintenant je plus de vélo je me
suis claqué un mollet pas une fois mais
vingt fois puis là je commence à courir
il me fait mal fait que tu fous mais le
ch donne à toi si tu te blesses scipion
dit tu peux plus faire de la course à
pied qui se fait
avant avait autre chose que la natation
de ces la qos et amener ça va être autre
chose sur touche pas on a parlé il ya je
pense que le plus important peu importe
c'est quoi c'est d'avoir une passion
nous avons de quoi mais mettons l'idée
mais ce que j'aime dans la natation
c'était m'améliorer moi même puis la
seconde où est ce que moi je pense pas
que j'aurais été capable de continuer
une carrière mais ton si on voit me
catherine savoir qui est venu ici les
traits que son meilleur temps à vie aux
deux centrales à la fête en 2010 est
plus là s'en rapproche pour la première
fois depuis 2007 moi je pense pas que
j'aurais été capable de faire sur de
continuer une carrière pendant trois
quatre ans à ne plus faire mes
meilleures performances et je pense
gérard ethève à l'arrêt donc que je
continue c'est parce que je continuais à
lui aussi toujours mais si pas la courte
si cette [ __ ] à mieux faire du vélo
aussi le comme toi même ton oui mais si
c'est intéressant cette notion-là de il
faut que j'aie quelque chose pour être
en amélioration constante est-ce que
c'est pas une erreur de penser ça est-ce
que c'est pas une erreur de se dire je
vais toujours être meilleur pis si ça
revient l'idée sur est-ce que je suis
bien avec ce que j'ai est ce que par
exemple de faire 1 5 km ou semaines 1 je
sais pas moi 35 minutes ça me suffit est
ce que dans notre société
on nous a habitués à se suffire ou être
c fait une partie de notre vie non non
non très rarement de soi dire tu atteins
ce niveau là parce qu'il n'y paraît
jamais jamais on nous induit l'idée
selon laquelle faut toujours faire mieux
et c'est là que je me demandais ce que
pas un problème avec ça peut vite il y
en a beaucoup qui disent il faut
apprendre à décélérer c'est le livre de
léo stréliski qui dit en gros faut
apprendre à ralentir dans notre vie il
faut apprendre à se déployer il faut
apprendre à se défaire de cette rapidité
qu'on nous met partout faut tout faire
plus vite plus rapide que sais je suis
vraiment pas un modèle à tulle ma blonde
te dirai je fais 15 choses en même temps
j'ai 72 projets quand j'en fais jusqu'à
six malades en pis peut-être que c'est
le moment de ma vie où est ce que je me
dis j'ai moins besoin de me prouver
c'est aussi c'est peut-être important
parce que quand tu es jeune tu dis je
veux exister j'ai besoin d'être reconnue
autant parmi parc par moi même pour me
dire je sers à quelque chose qui le
sport permettent de le faire parce que
tu dis je m'améliore je suis meilleur
donc je me réalise c'est sur la
transcendance être meilleur dans quelque
chose faite la transcendance par le
support si un jour puis d'homme tôt ça
peut être par la musique si la
transcendance parce que vous qualifiez
de passion ne vient plus de cette
passion là qu'est ce que tu fais ou est
ce que tu vas est ce que tu dis je vais
remettre en question cette idée là deux
meilleurs ou de plus haut plus vite plus
fort pour aller vers quelque chose
d'autre
puis en ce moment le recalibrage de
notre société puis quand tu regardes la
jeunesse qui eux sont pas nécessairement
dans l'idée où je veux une grosse car
annonce on peut décemment tous là dedans
est-ce qu'on peut un peu raison puis
dans le sport je te dis ça parce que
quand tu regardes naomi osaka saint
simon ammann ou stéphane richer
dernièrement qui sont sortis ou jonathan
droit qui disent c'est dur quand j'y
arrive pas puis dans matin l'impression
l'autre on se rend du rhin puis on se
dit ben bravo la gagne parce que c'est
pas un premier pas pour dire la
performance sportive à tout prix le
culte de la performance n'est pas
nécessairement nécessairement ce que
mieux dans le sport ou dans la vie parce
qu'on se alice pas parce qu'on tue des
gens à vouloir les rendre tout le temps
meilleurs comme dans une usine
d'accéder notion intéressante club tu
vois que le sport permet de tester
certaines notions petit on parle
beaucoup de santé mentale depuis la
polémique même avant puis le fait que
salman base
l'évoquent ouvertement ou l'histoire de
jonathan drouin on le savait tout ce qu
on attendait qu'ils nous le disent
ouvertement mais tabarouette mais c'est
comme n'importe quoi tirer des bombes
dit les positifs des négatifs il n'est
pas dans l'excès devient négatif le tipi
le sport à sa base activité physique
promouvoir l'activité physique c'est
positif comment promouvoir
prévalant pour l'esprit sportif c'est
positif peine valeurs qui sont
excellentes qui poussé à l'extrême
le deviennent deviennent des cercles de
bonbons est ce que c'est que le tir puis
aussi je pense que c'était 7 drive le
de toujours vouloir s'améliorer à
quelque chose pour pousser plus loin la
limite c'est pas une triste un trait de
personnalité je pense beaucoup je pense
qu'une certaine personne à qui ils l'ont
vraiment un wicked il a parlé avec jean
philippe haute encore une fois il dit et
yvonne être accepte ma réaction ti cats
cantos est-ce que cela ne va rien c'est
ça la grande question est ce que est ce
que ça t'a été comment dire construit
par la société à laquelle tu vis ou
s'était entouré des deux jeux machines
parce que tu es c'est vrai quel
parallèle antivaleurs capitalisme et les
valeurs du sport sont liés cefac changer
un système si on vivait dans un monde
qu'ils étaient différents parlements que
les valeurs je prévois qu'il laisse par
ailleurs dans le niveau d'importance
quand il accorde dans société se regarde
la société marxiste de l'urss parce que
je sais qu'ils renoncent moment qu'ils
vont dire que je suis marxiste dans mon
approche plus beau du tout au contraire
je pense que le sport c'est au un
vecteur démocratique mais l uam dans
l'urss c'est exactement le même type de
valeurs de performance et pourtant
n'était pas dans une société capitaliste
mais on t'aime dans un culte de la
performance qui n'est pas propre au
capitalisme c'est le culte de la
performance
puis de l'explosion des records
il y en a beaucoup qui prône je veux
faire du millage lorsque tu te dis aime
beaucoup qui prône pour les olympiques
qu'on remette les records à zéro parce
que trop de records ont été faits dopés
puis on n'est plus capable d évaluer
puis l' agence antidopage qui est à
montréal vont nous dire oui mais on a
toutes les les comment dire ils viennent
des athlètes qu'on est capable de voir
puis de remonter pour les tester au delà
tout ça moi je serais pour on remet les
compteurs à les compteurs à zéro gagne
puis on va voir au 20 ans des nouveaux
records à une génération chossat plus
logique de compote si quand tu compares
johnny wegmüller qui est un agent à
michael phelps tu fais oui mais non à la
limite si on veut comparer des lutteurs
de la grèce antique aux lutteurs
d'aujourd'hui ça ça marche pas c'est pas
les mêmes notions n'ont pas c'est johnny
moss mais là avait pas un physio avait
pas un nutritionniste avait pas un
préparateur mental y avait pas une
équipe autour de lui il travaillait pas
70 en piscine peut-être que oui j'ai pas
évalué mais tu es fou comparer avec 6
comparable je pense que
ça ça nous color beaucoup la vie de
penser qu' on va toujours battre un
record parce qu'à m'amener là tu dis ya
une limite petites perches on en avait
parlé sur toi toi et moi quand est venue
tourner un marathon en moins de deux
heures le test a été fait ils ont fait
le yo ké what's next note ce texte un
marathon 1h45 un marathon en une heure
et demie puis ce fait rendu là
mettez des robots mais mettez des robots
vous voulez tout le temps du plus vite
puis c'est la grande question la suite
du sport c'est si tu regardes des
athlètes sportif au hockey tu dis ben
programmant des robots qui vont vous
offrir des performances de plus en plus
folle que ça va être des objets qu'on va
faire pour faire des performances de
plus en plus folle parce que le corps a
une limite le corps une limite mais il
n'y a pas un peu dans cette idée là je
te demande vouloir essayer de la trouver
c'est peep-toe ces deux de fans aux
frontières
oui peut-être limites sauf que sauf que
et où c'est parce qu'il me semble qu'ils
aient toujours tu aimé ton jeu même la
pousser dans l'ouest l'est est tout le
temps l'idée de oui ça serait des états
unis qui se sont construits sur la tête
de repousser la frontière de voir et
whoopi sais pas je ne sais pas propre à
maintenant de six vouloir voir tim et
ont largement cormier comment vit-on et
kara de courir jusqu où on est capable
d'aller puis je veux aussi amener la
question de
setubal du doping puis on peut parler du
doping oui physique mais aussi le doping
mécanique très justement dans dans
breaking tout le le la course des lieux
de crypto gay pour faire un bot deux
heures il ya beaucoup de débats sur les
souliers les fameux souliers en fibre de
carbone il ya eu ce débat lost michael
phelps la combinaison des bolt gay en
natation parce que on est on est
retournés on a quand même ouvert la
boîte de pandore au pis pour une raison
x on a réussi à leur faire mal de faire
acquis social est le but de ces maillots
long on n'a plus le droit de porter les
maillots en polyuréthane puis le ont pu
malgré tout les records se sont battus à
l'exception de deux qui demande encore
le thé qui ont été faites à l'époque des
maillots mais le tout les records sont
fait battre après mais il ya quand même
c'est cette idée là on dirait de vouloir
voir à qui mettons qu'on utilise mettons
qu'on comprend le corps humain et qu'on
la dise yonne à la technologie puis
quand je pars ou la connaissance quand
je parle de ça je parle pas juste de les
maillots le doping mais je parle aussi
de qu'est-ce qu'on connaît sur les
méthodes d'entraînement qu'est ce qu'on
connaît sur le sur la physio la
nutrition ces choses là
jusqu'où est ce qu'on est capable
d'amener
l'humain qui cette quête là vont
nécessairement au détriment
de
certains individus t on au juste à
penser à yao ming qui qui a été ses
parents dans le fond ces deux chinois
les plus grand possible puis qui se font
reproduire lui est élevé avec un ballon
de basket dans ses mains à jouer 365
jours par année au basket et au
détriment de cet humain loeb on est
quand même quand même été capable de
voir qu est ce qu un être humain de
cette es6 qui qui joue au basket tout
les jours d'année capable de faire
évidemment vols intérieurs très
restreint parce qu'ils sont encore le
lâcher après puis est tout seul les
hormones de croissance l'ont rattrapé
sauf que il semble que cette pensée le
qu'on peut faire le parallèle avec la
frontière d'exploration spatiale la
frontière
la frontière roumaine aussi à partir de
quand on va se dire ben on va mettre des
prothèses ont valeur ajoutée un
stimulant musculaire le neurologue qui
démasque avec sa silhouette voit que le
spa puis je te dis moi le sport faut que
ça ait des règles - comme en formule 1
jenson grand fan de formule 1 depuis un
moment donné quand tu avais räikkönen
qui avait une voiture tellement plus
rapide que les autres fai ben non gagne
un problème là une auto pareil pour tout
le monde
les pilotes mais ce que tu veux voir
s'il est capable de séparer l'humain
d'un autre humain puis quand la
technologie est plus forte si je te
donne un autre exemple grande figure un
nom grâce nos qui était le gardien des
flyers de philadelphie il y avait des
bad tu est des jambières tellement à
grosse île était grillé tegra un
équipement faisait juste se mettre
devant le but des orques 3 cm de chaque
bord qui bougeait pas c'est bien on
gagne ça se peut pas faut réduire fauqué
des limites c'est là que tu vois que si
les lignes en quelque sorte mettre leurs
culottes pour dire voici les limites du
hockey pouvait pas aller en dessous
c'est pas votre courbe et votre bâton
parce que si on le sait les canadiennes
morel ont gagné une coupe stanley parce
que le bâton de marquer mais ça aurait
été trop courbé charlotte à jacques
demers là dessus que c'est qu'il est
sorti au bon moment mais ce peut pas
laisser libre cours à tous à 6 pi du
sport mais je veux amener une nuance
dans les exemples de demain parce que
admettons qu'on veut comparer la qualité
de pilote oui faisons une ligue où est
ce que tout le monde a le même véhicule
puis on voit vraiment c'est qui le
meilleur pilote par contre dans mettons
l'exemple la formule 1 you can only un
concours de mécano c'est au même site
qui aimait tant
télé les espèces de caen s'appelait a à
z télé les robots qui se battent l
abattoir abattoirs au même titre que
rabat oiseaux parce que là c'était des
écuries capables de faire le meilleur
robot effectifs qui ont un peu ça aussi
dans la f1 que je trouve cool vie dans
ce genre de sport là où est ce que oui
le sport pile l'athlète si on veut
comparer les athlètes on leur donne ce
la même chose on compare les pilotes
puis il ya des ligues sûr que c'est seul
je tenais pas assez la course automobile
pour sa bourse mais il ya aussi quelque
chose de cool de dire ok match une
grosse compagnie de l'argent tu mets de
l'argent dans le développement dans la
recherche et développement pour essayer
puis qui a été la meilleure voiture que
je peux même aller plus loin et si
certains des plus grands pilotes et et
travailler sur le tour michael
schumacher jean gabin le défaut majeur
dernièrement c'est quand ils racontaient
était le dernier à sortir des parcs
pascal gauci sur son auto pour être sûr
de l'as été correctement sur la ferrari
et qui reçoit au sipi tau raison de le
dire sauf que un autre documentaire à
voir absolument c'est celui sur ayrton
senna qui sur les trains icx qui était
pas initialement sur netflix se voit
qu'à un moment donné les voitures
étaient tellement rend tellement
dangereuse que les gosses tu es un lui
dis
ça marche pull et encore une fois ce qui
se passait pas réglementée et piqué ont
fait pousser des athlètes dans des
laboratoires centres d'entraînement
conchou tête sorte d'harmonie combos
différents croquis civile dragon bat
ivan drago si c'est le meilleur le
meilleur par un montage est heureux
qu'il s'entraîne avec des bouts de bois
par ivan drago qui condamne à un certain
embarras mais couple hallyday
[Rires]
[Musique]
bref à manille moralement il ya des
choses qu'on peut pas accepter wipro qui
a une conscience morale c'est les points
qui est en train d'apporter son pot pour
diminuer le sport
en consomme écrit sur le sport
je suis né dans le sport si je me levais
le matin jouerait le soleil qui est un
cahier des sports je regardais ce les
nordiques avait encore perdu
[Musique]
mais je regardais succès le goulet avait
fait des points parce que c'était mon
joueur favori je regardais sports 30
c'est la première chose que je regarde
est systématiquement mais à un moment
donné tu dit c'est comme la politique
j'adore la politique mais quand tu vois
que il ya de la corruption s'est arrangé
avec le gars des vues puis on se fait
fourrer quelques parties de ben non ça
marche pas puis tu peut adorer la chose
mais la détester en même temps je pense
que si tu n'as pas ton une attitude
critique par rapport au sport il ya un
problème parce que tu deviens lié n'est
toi même tu ne vois que le le plaisir
que ça t'apporte sans voir les
désagréments que sa cause à l'athlète
finances du point de vue humain du point
de vue physique aussi parce que c'est
des décors qui sont cassés aussi et
quand j'écoutais un reportage hier sur
1,1 mafiosi j'ai dit miguel hanté que h
une équipe adam brideau acquis pour son
fils de will be dancing
puis y engage des gones puis le but
c'est de refaire slapshot carrément
pieds raconte l'histoire d'un club qui
est david beauregard que ce soit pour
saint-hyacinthe qui était repêché par
les sharks de san jose se sait pas dans
le fil dans le documentaire c'est moi
qui suis allé chercher à se ré wiki pour
voir ce qu'ils avaient pu le regretter
super bon mais ammann et ça ramasse en
échappée puis un gars qui lève le bâton
soul alicia tri par un oeil sa carrière
et finissent ramasse dans les ligues
subalternes dont celle là c'est là que
tu vois que licka y en a bien un goon
amman et il se fait tous tes la jambe
puis le patin carrément à l'envers puis
on n'entend pas dans le reportage parce
qu'ils y ont eu l'intelligence de
palmettes mais dit tous les gens qui
étaient les dix ans n'a jamais entendu
des cris de douleur de cette manière là
c'est le tube à la limite du sport
moines de celle qui m'avait marqué comme
je vous dis un grand fan de soccer puis
de l'équipe de france djibril cissé je
passais audi quelque soit attaquant de
l'équipe de france que jouer pour le
auxerre qui à un moment donné c'était si
quoi cassé le tibia péroné mais vraiment
un tibia péroné sont en dessous du genou
pour ce qu'ils savent paul est un jour à
la préparation de la coupe du monde
dernier match de préparation avant la
coupe du monde il se fait repérer le
tibia péroné et les cris de douleur qui
à ce moment là c'est inhumain c'est là
les limites physiques de certains
sportifs la même manière c'est
christiane ericsson qui fait un arrêt
cardiaque à l'euro
ils sont intervenus c'est là que tu as
vu quand même si j'étais un peu fiers
les caméras se sont reculés les joueurs
lyonnais du foyer ont montré sur six est
correct parce qu'à un moment donné il ya
des limites pis y'a comme un point
moratoire mais une moralité ou est ce
qu'on dit quand quelqu'un qui est mort
du présent de police images ne montrent
pas signé image est pourtant une des
images qui a le plus tourné ses scènes
la mort d'ayrton senna ouais si tu vas
sur netflix tu vois sur une voie facile
tout et la pige à gauche c'était gilles
villeneuve même chose
betty quand tu dis on veut voir jusqu'où
la limite c'est parce que si pour nous
amener à la limite ça entraîne des morts
est-ce que du point de vue éthique
on peut l'expliquer on peut légitiment
c'est là que dans la réponse dans
questions mais oui on peut penser c'est
comme le hacker pourquoi il ya encore
des batailles au hockey à partir de
quand c'est quand max pacioretty s'est
fait rentrer dans bande parce de nos
chars ans qu'est-ce qu'on fait les gens
ils ont appelé la police
pour dénoncer un attentat puis gary
bettman qui nous allons tout va bien
quand ctek east et suzuki- quand ces
faits très ramassée par un coup de poing
devant les yeux de l'arbitré n'y a pas
eu de pénalité tout le monde dit ça n'a
pas de bon sens si bettman qui dit on
est les meilleurs arbitres de noms du
sport professionnel il ya quelque chose
de pourri
je déteste quand la culture du sport le
seul oui mais non du pauvre simon à la
culture du sport du rock in oui mais tu
peux avoir une culture du sport qui est
différente entre ennemis on se respecte
on çà prisme et les bâtisses ces
conversations que j'ai avec des gars qui
ont joué au hockey jusqu'à des bons
niveaux voire la ligue nationale qui me
disent que ça fait partie du respect
entre les équipes se sait si c'est
justement un code 2d le vu le
c'était
pendant les séries je crois que c'était
connu car en matière américain le cdn
travers moi qui ai ramassé tavares
plotegher via le web ce qui
règle mais on règle ça puis m'ont fait
ce après sucer les consciences 3000 pour
nous à l'extérieur on voit ce ont fait
ça pas de bon sens puis à l'intérieur
les gambettes candidats or si ceux qui
ceux qui quittent étrange mouche comme
toi je regarde sur l'extérieur je me
dise en présence mais quand qui font des
sondages chez les joueurs la grand
majorité pour manquer ça reste oui mais
rendu le csic tu dis il ya beaucoup de
gens aussi au canada qui sont pour le
rétablissement de la peine de mort ouais
t'es rendu là
moralement ça se tient pas
éthiquement ça
[Musique]
mais quand tu vas avec tc familial le
sport c'est l'éducation la citoyenneté
l'éducation à la société tu vois des
enfants qui hurlent dessus le tube puis
c'est une école aussi du racisme que tu
peux avoir le sport quand tu vois que
certains joueurs se font hurler des
choses qui des insanités ou font des
gestes inacceptables et pitau des
enfants qui sont satisfaits non vous
êtes des modèles de la société ces
choses ne passent plus puis le hac est
un des rares sports où tu encore des
batailles
normale et surtout les gars
ils sont sur patins en plomb équilibre
l'ipo facile chez bain qui font leur vie
là dessus métier georges laraque comment
prendre un exemple je me souviens
stall taille un titre et l'allemagne
avaient mis un micro je le voyais était
et a mis en jeu puis j'ai dit
ok colloque les arts sega qu'il ramasse
fait si un peu côté le lit le pugilat
pythie les espèces d'espèces de grosses
virilité incarner petit dit oui mais non
c'est normal qu'un gars comme sidney
crosby a eu trop de commotion cérébrale
ce pas normal que des gars qui sortent
de là qu'ils ont des problèmes
à 28 ans que leur vie finit par se sont
fait trop rentrer dans band ou des
supposés d'un côtes alors que c'est pas
ça le sport laissez pas rebuter ton
adversaire c'est de mettre le lac rawdon
et dans le filet adverse le site ces
questions qui se posent pour le football
aussi pipeau église pas de combos et
puis tout laisse croire événement s'est
tous dit sport que l'éthique est
justement lui une partie qui sont
commotionnés qui sont ils ces qu'est la
vie nos primes oui mais c'est certes un
sport je comprends que du contact mais
du contact volontairement inutiles qui
dessert le sport un bosseur bonsoir ça
vaut la peine 6 e au basket des fleurs
quelqu'un au volant le frapper un hôte
fini je veux même pas savoir où tu finis
tolérance zéro puis ok c'est majeur ou
quoi que ce soit c'est comme tout bas t
out une semaine c'est le joueur de
vancouver qui ramasse et jake evans dont
j'oublie le nom
de wintek j'ai dit vingt coureurs dont
shai for pi lui piquent les autres
joueurs à la retraite du bain
les veines au regard des attaches un
petit tour non c'est pas de sa faute
l'autre le ramasser même palais pour la
la rondelle c'est comme mourir chasser
fait ramasse parce qu'il ya tapé un
arbitre puis là il y aurait pu tuer un
groupe c c'est la grande question c'est
certains chroniqueurs sportifs se disent
ben il va falloir un mort va falloir
qu'il ya un mort dans la ligue nationale
pour que ce soit violent qui est un
changement de mentalité puis ça c'est
l'idée selon laquelle on vous pousse à
la limite si je peux d'accord - aucun
problème je comprend justement
chaque faire il ya fait une publicité
aux legs c'est un groupe ben arfa je
poste sur l'île comme dans le fond il ya
sortie jack events des playoffs en y
rentrant dedans vraiment quand même
assez sauvage mal parce que dans les
cercles du doigt une mise en échec mais
comme vraiment pas nécessaire
puisqu'il disait lui c'est faux tout le
temps que tu lèves la tête relève la
tête tu m'aurais venir métier c'est
complètement con passtime novembre sauf
qu'il ya fait une publicité un gros big
boy de cet été à winnipeg c'est lui qui
n'a même pas si marqué eyes on the road
body avec ce genre c'est que c'est un
peu un clin d'oeil à soupe c'est une
scène laissé lucho qui glorifie ce genre
d'acte la wii maisons et tuent banalise
alors que les gens m'a rien fait pas par
quoi ça pas de bon sens que pour donner
le contexte c'était un but dans un filet
désert le match était fini il ya les
marques et c'était sûr puis-je iphone
les parties carrément du but des
canadiens a traversé la glace fait que
là ça faisait tout ça
va très vite puis le contact shay
fauchard il faut mais dzeko était de
derrière le filet qui veulent mettre
comme ça donc ils regardent la rondelle
qui ont tu peux pas regarder en haut et
chats il faut lui rentrer dedans
moi je les ai vus j'ai fait il est
paraplégique 1 est paraplégique
automatique puis ça je dois regarder ce
dc avait été quadraplégique ci était
mort sur le coup
cela qu'on veut en venir mais je vous
rappelle rien à faire comme cela était
arrivé le 7 et todd bertuzzi qui avait
pas tant le genre par en arrière il
avait fini la carrière de l'autre joueur
mais je le faisais s'est fait planter
dans la banque était pour chicago les
images sont affreuses puis tu le vois
commotion cérébrale le seul coup puis
regarde le plafond du forum à l'époque
puis comme ça ne vous me voyez pas ce
qui m'attendait mais il ya les îles et
les doigts qui pointe vers le ciel tu
sens que le guilly les pilotes auteurs
comme métier des fois faut que tu en
viennent à seclin malarchuk qui était un
gardien que ces faits sectionné l'aorte
avec un patin c'est l'autre qui sont
s'est rendu compte bon il y avait du
sang partout cherchez pas les images on
n'en trouve plus c'est là qu'on s'est
rendu compte faut qu'ils aient un
médecin d'urgence à chaque match c'est
là que certains gardiens ont commencé à
avoir une espèce de de protection
supplémentaire sous le masque en
plastique pour les protéger des coups de
pas m'en passer dangereux ce sport c'est
pour ça que c'est comme il ya déjà sept
danger de même race et se répondent et
bataille c'est pour ça que mon chien
puis en plus je le déteste des semaines
d'autant plus parce qu'il veut pas
donner nos aînés qui pourra québec là il
va [ __ ] des équipes à l'endroit où il
n'y a jamais eu neige
je trouve que l'équipe de vegas est une
insulte au wac est selon moi le pilote
en plus quand tu regardes et les avant
matches avec guest dit pendant sa queue
puis vous dont des caisses nous au togo
sur piste excusez-moi j'ai fait un petit
bien senti le jour la majorité des gens
vont penser comme comme comme nous sur
les batailles en europe une naissance
qui ont répondu
présent la tension baisse parce que je
pense je pense que si on avait pas je
pense forcément créé tant que ça si tu
regardes le kenya le but actuel le titre
que je suis d'accord avec tout ça manque
répondre dans le fond la magnitude et
gagne fini sur tous les types de joie
qui n'existerait plus non tu sais c'est
le type de joueur le goum l'un pour
déménager ça dessert le sport puis quand
je regarde sidney crosby quand tu
regardes du guillaume latendresse ur des
voix en vrai elle est fait son gros way
section pour besoin d'avoir un goon en
plus déjà il se bat bien plus qu à
paraître dans bangla ceux qui ont jamais
vu de à qui faut que tu les vois
physiquement un cd enfants ont des
visages d'enfants ils sont bâtis comme
des lutteurs de la wwf
c'est des armes carrément sur patins
cd cd des spécimens de bon spécimen tu
vois si de même les mettons les joueurs
de basket les plus petits ils sont
communs à ces trois depuis son petit lit
quand même assez incroyable
ouais ouais
bien que au début le tu nous parlais de
de ce qu'il fallait faire pour les
studios le tout est un fan de soul de
quoi des studios de faisait maintenant
mais les studios et
les sujets sur la glace oui en fait pour
ceux qui connaissent pamiers acquis les
studios ghibli en fait qui font des
films d'animation sont rendus tout sur
netflix en 10 sélections
acheté le catalogue
totoro le château ambulant
chiffres
sont là knight vinke puis c'est vrai
mais c'est so sick manille quand tu veux
présenter quelque chose à des enfants ou
est-ce que c'est pas toujours la mère
qui meurt le père qui meurt après ce
faux qui il combat permanent
des fois c'est juste poétique pinto
toros est très bon parce que tu es c'est
l'histoire d'un père qui achètent une
maison avec ses deux enfants ses deux
filles sa prof d'université fait que je
m'associe beaucoup à sa piscine m mais
j'en ai deux pis les enfants qu'est ce
qu'ils font bien y vivent pis ils
tombent amoureux un peu de la forêt puis
les s'invente un personnage qui ce gros
gros esprit de la forêt qui est au
taureau qui se passe pas grand chose
dans le film le ya plein de choses plein
de gens qui ont dit ah ben non au
contraire c'est une quête de sens de la
vie mais c'est décider de manière très
simple puis la musique est absolument
captivant pisé l'optique d'un cinéma
autre que le cinéma de disney puissant
qui peut se faire pour les enfants qui
leur apprend quelque chose de plus fort
que simplement bon bah écoutez
je dis ça mais obsédante sur les
émotions si vous l'avez jamais vu bon
c'est parfait pour apprendre des
émotions aux enfants mais toujours est
il que pour revenir sous studio ghibli
je veux faire quelque chose sur
l'histoire
du studio ghibli pilée référence
japonaise d esprit qu on voit pas ce
qu'on parle de shiro là dedans avec tous
les esprits qu'on voit qu'ils sont de la
mythologie japonaise là dedans mais je
compte bien faire quelque chose inouïe
quand j'ai découvert ce cinéma le 2 mai
à qui je devais trop ou secondaire keith
a vraiment été
c'était des foyers des choses qui
croisent sa route dans vie petit et jean
puis bon moment puisque ce sujet j'ai
jamais vue subie je savais pas que ça
existait une
révélation qui je me suis je suis c'est
qu'elle que j'avais écouté en premier je
pense que princesse mononoké à ces
violences s'est impliqué plus vieux
prendre le plus violent d'après ces
chiots pis je me souviens
j'avais jamais vu supplanter le jeu peut
pas croire
je pouvais pas croire que quelqu'un
avait une imagination assez
fertile bien assez incroyable pour pour
accoucher de sauvetage il ya tellement
d'imagés tellement de styles de monstres
demande idées visuelles que
j'étais complètement à l'abri fabregas t
par
l'originalité puis imagination et
d'ailleurs
mais à juste titre raison quand tu dis
l'originalité c'est que c'est un monde
premièrement auquel on n'est pas habitué
parce que c'est un monde qui n'est pas
occidental
c'est pas une mythologie à laquelle on
est habitués mais qui nous parlent très
bien passé là la grande force de la
mythologie en général qu'elle soit
nordique grecques romaines ou autochtone
qu'on connaît beaucoup moins mais dieu
sait qu'elle va pas du tout body shop a
juste le windigo ya plein d'autres
histoires à faire là dessus puis on
pourrait le faire ici parce que tu es
des trucs très formaté on en a vu alors
que ce n'est pas du tout formaté mais
c'est une critique t du pôle de shirwa
moment donné c'est qu'il ya une scène
qui est magnifique c'est que les parents
qui sont en voiture avec shiro elle
s'endort dans la voiture de son père ou
une espèce de vieux parc d'amusement
puis décide d'y aller puis arrive dans
ce parc le pied de la bouffe de la
bouffe une vie décide de manger puis le
l'a fait là les petites rides mais papa
faut pas faire ça faut pas faire ça mais
dit en fait projet de l'argent puis au
prg des cartes de crédit bio y mange
mange y mange le chinois se retourne
puis cantat revient à vos ses parents
qui sont devenus des cochons puis les
cochons s'est hissée animaux forme
chercher giorgio rwanda de cette société
qui se consume par elle-même puis elle
est confrontée aux esprits qui
renaissent en pleine nuit il faut
qu'elle se sauver elle-même l'a écouté
c'est une quête
de soi dans l'ancienne mythologie
japonaise distincts c'est un pied de nez
que femi acquis aussi à la société
capitaliste pour dire voici tout ce que
vous avez oublié watts ici tout ce qui
faisait l'unicité du japon que vous avez
balayé du revers de la main au profit la
capitalisation examen et je passais pour
un an un anticapitalisme
pas du tout pas du tout je peins
anticapitaliste du tout mais ces films
là nous donne de l'espoir nous donne
puis princesse mononoké c'est drôle
parce que même si c'est des films
extrêmement violent je les présente aux
enfants puis mon fils de 7 ans qu'à y
entend la musique de princesse mononoké
malgré lui commence à pleurer parce que
c'est la mort dans le monde le monde
l'esprit des forêts qui se fait tuer par
le monde des hommes qui eux veulent tout
détruire avatar rien inventé mais non
ainsi que pis on eu beaucoup moissonner
dans le cinéma américain pour aller
chercher les derniers acquis pour
essayer de les tourner à la sauce
américaine mais les affadir puis rendent
tellement comestibles comme en ayons pu
degoul c'est quand tu disais tout à
l'heure à trop vouloir plaire à tout le
monde on plaît à personne qui me acquis
c'est comme ça complexe ça va chier
vous allez trouver sur des gueux manif
m'en fous c'est ça pis si souvent un
genre de sous texte environnementale un
grand mentaliste dans ses films tipi
bein avant séoul un de ses plus vieux
c'est no 6 que je pense que oui pis et
c'est ultra environnementalistes comme
film que je suis sait quelle année
métier cci si longtemps le titre dansant
ce qui existe et c'était pas le sujet de
l'heure à l'époque lust épaules
l'urgence qu'on connaît aujourd'hui qui
déjà de ses valeurs l'ops propos le
étaient présents il va falloir revenir
pour faire un truc jeu sur studio ghibli
parce que mes faut que ça soit plus
connue déjà ici je dis ça mais on a
quand même beaucoup qu'ils connaissent
là
aujourd'hui et aujourd'hui quand on
parle d'un film à quelqu'un d'un fort en
tant que tel feront un bon travail
question de laisser son honnêteté c'est
tout le
club aujourd'hui tu veux pouvoir par les
supporters gardent si la réponse est non
la vous fais tu le sais qu'elle
encadrait à vos pots à lait la louer sur
youtube plus youtube à porter ou pour
saint piat ce pas compliqué voir un film
80 m en voir un film mais si c'est par
les flics c'est maintenant c'est sa
large des gens voient pas où ils
écouteront jamais mais leur maintenance
parler c'est fabuleux qui a personne à
ces questions de taux pour répondre oui
toi là-bas j'étais assez content
dernièrement lost in translation est
revenue sur netflix avait été sur
netflix pluie est revenue monsieur mon
film préféré fait que chaque fois que
j'en parle à quelqu'un choquer mais
hélas encryption plus
obscurs commencera muscat tahsin
transmission avant la survenue sur
netflix fait que la chaque fois que je
le pose le posant une conversation j'ai
voté la sécrétion de faire des films
quand même malgré tout système marc
andré lussier qui disait je t'ai pas
tout de suite marc-andré lucie
chroniqueur à la presse le cinéma qui
disait t'es pas tout de suite vos dvd
parce qu'il ya plein de films qui ne
sont pas convertis par exemple président
jean marc vallée qui moi et il fait
remarquer et puis les droits si les
droits de la marque à
payer la musique tu vas voir il sent sa
vie trop difficile pour 15 ans lui c'est
un marché qui se venge en brenil sens
pour 15 ans puis on verra pas ce que
c'est juste pas les moyens le saf et ça
fait sept ans lol c'est fait il peut
plus rire sortir sont faibles plus
rééditer son firmes et les on dit qu'ils
ont réussi ce marc-andré annoncé qu' il
y allait leur place et j'ai tellement de
voir ce film là la magie le dvd chez
nous mais en plus
mais il ya plein de choses que tu
trouves pas sur les plates formes ouais
c'est tout le plaisir d'avoir
physiquement les choses pour soi puis
moi je suis quelqu'un je t'invite
schiste quand même de l'objet c'est à
vue chez nous le nombre de livres il
faut que j'aie la chose si j'ai le choix
entre consulter livres sur internet ou
physiquement ils font l'objet parce que
tu le fais tu et à toi tu notes un décor
n'est pas à jeter il commence à vivre
avec ce que topi je reste un plaisir oui
moi c'est ce que j'en parle souvent pour
la musique ses rangs du dématérialisé
vraiment puis j'ai jamais consommé
autant de musique le groupe tout un
album mais je développe jamais le même
attachement qu'un album que j'ai eus
fise et quand j'ai eu ces mais le retour
du vinyle aussi cessé pour compenser
beaucoup sur cette perte ne l'objectif
est d'ouvrir la pochette petit louis
josé houde en fait tellement le camp
effet l'adisq et ouvre les pochettes
pied regarde les remerciements mais qui
fait sont aujourd'hui d'ouvrir la
pochette moi je me souviens quand j'en
ai jeté
les cassettes audio lethu déroulé
carrément toute la pochette qui tu
lisais souvent ce que tu fais c'est que
tel à acheter un autre que moi quand je
la québec d'aller au 1o hmv quand ça
existait puis d'acheter la cassette
survenait en autobus puis entre temps tu
préparais la tête en lisant tout ce
qu'il y avait sur la pochette alors
qu'aujourd'hui c'est lui barre le noir
je l'écoutais de suite puis tu prends
même pas le temps de contextualiser mais
tu vois le bar le nord par exemple lui
parce que l'ajustement le plus proche de
ne plus la peine de faire un beau livre
est super avant que c'était vraiment
serré parties civiles le fait ou sainte
agathe et intégrante de l'expérience
d'avoir un album jamais de regarder le
livre est gardé par heure kahn est ce le
lui fait un jour de manif est le genre
de préambule la musique de l'isesco
lisez ce texte afin que l'album puis
chamaillard tournant par lee disait
dimanche était comme à l'opéra
mais un contexte de l'histoire de ce
pays bas sur ce qu appliquer qui ramène
oui de forme dans mon père aussi des
fois avec c'est est ce que
tu es
la menace fantôme vous allez beaucoup
ce qui donne à celui à 5 ans mais j'y
crois pas
et c'est pas vrai manit voit ce qu'on a
perdu pis
il y avait du beau quand même dans
l'ancien je suis pas du tout celui qui
dit faut revenir aux vente' jeou ce
poste quelqu'un qui est nostalgique à
l'os mais je pense que on avait des
choses qui fonctionnait pas réglé mais
pied levé neil je trouve que c'est ça
les gens qui apprécient la musique
souvent reviennent aux vinyles parce que
l'album et est fermé c'est à dire quand
on finit album sur spotify va pour muse
éclat qui participe à quelque chose
autre où cet ami random de l'album tu en
profites pas comme il était conscient
alors qu'elle venait lui a pas le choix
faut que tu écoutes du début à la fin
bon c'est sûr que tu peux changer
l'aiguillé il met sa ferme l'expérience
de la même manière qu'un livre s'affirme
l'expérience c'est ce qu'on disait tout
à l'heure quand vous ouvrez le podcast
c'est que le livre dit papa fureter avec
des notifications c'est là dedans un
fait quelque chose de bien de ce coupé
du monde pendant quelques jours
de l'ouverture d'un galop mais c'était
comme ça marche avant marche et ses
quatre métiers des lecteurs jouer ta
marché
pilote amis j'ai écouté un reportage
fascinant là dessus de bloomberg qui est
sur youtube puis expliquer comment ça se
fait qu'on a cassé la musique à partir
de campi fait toute l'histoire de
napster a pour music qui explique que
nature tout foutu en l'air mais celui le
grand destructeur de la musique 7 et
steve jobs il dit quand ils négocier
avec les maisons de disques pour que les
taux ne soit 99 scène il fait exploser
le concept d'album parce que dorénavant
les gens achetaient les vitrines donnent
à 1 puis 10 à renverser complètement
parce que dans les années 90 les gens
paient de cette pièce 20 pierre 1 25 $
pour un album pour avoir une tonne
souvent ils disent les maisons disent se
remplissent les poches vraiment jusqu'à
ce qu'un abstrait arrive puis tu vois
comment peu à peu tous a été intégrée
par un nouveau système qui dès que d'un
spotify puis à pour music mais de
comprendre où est ce que ça chier c'est
super intéressant ce reportage en trois
parties sur youtube ou total ça fait une
heure et demie ils vous irez voir so
c'est fascinant qui interviewent le
fondateur de napster et interviews les
gens de la pole puis les grands
spécialistes de commercialisation de la
musique c'est vraiment passionnant ces
impies mettons
on parle de son parle de venir l'on
parle de l'expérience album pl al de
l'autre bord complètement de drake qui
sort un album à toutes les années de 27
tonnes avec comme co veut des emoji
dudit
le télétravail mettons de de concision
de dire ok belge est pas infini de
l'espace je peux pas mettre 27 tonnes
faucheurs travail mais tous ne faut que
je refasse il faut que je travaille mes
textes faut que je travaille mon enfant
at work faut que je fasse ses délires
exclu gens m'ont pouvoir lire dans le
web il y aura le baril a perdu un petit
peu de preuves fais exactement la garde
de ce que tu dis lui il y avait signé
avec sa compagnie de disques puis il
voulait sortir plein plein plein
d'albums puis la compagnie scandinave un
nom un seul coup ça va être tout c'est
là que changer de nom pour de
l'espérance
ce qu'on sait pas ce qu'il voulait
sortir ses albums sous sa compagnie mais
la compagnie voulait pas fait qu'à faire
fort comme je le fire nextel à
l'histoire mais vous limitez ma
créativité je vais m'amuser avec ce que
grecque fait prince l'a fait avant lui
c'est juste que prince aujourd'hui la ek
watts et des albums de 75 tournoi pee
wee
bas
qui produisait
compulsivement de la musique là chaque
jour y aller dans son studio où il
enregistre est cpie semble celle que ddd
un vol twa ce qui est de la musique
comme des heures et des heures de
musique et qu'on verrait pas vraiment
jamais ou qui va sortir ou compte
gouttes
mais jean leloup qui disait que certains
voyages qui revenait de 300 tonnes
jusqu'à maintenant on va faire un album
devinez qui limitait sa à 40 40 ha minh
tu sais comment on dirait une bonne
longueur savez vous pourquoi les vinyles
en fait les albums font 60 minutes c'est
vous dire le nom de tour je suis non le
premier la première toune qu'on a mis
sur vinyle c'est la cinquième ou la
neuvième de beethoven siens puis
laquelle c'était le temps fait que celle
devenu l'étalon c'était sur une
symphonie de beethoven fait que la
raison pour laquelle les albums sont
construits comme ça c'est à cause de
beethoven encore une fois
qu'est ce qu'on regarde sur ta chance
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont en vie pour toi
ben là en fait il ya beaucoup de vidéos
qui s'en viennent bien noté sorti il y
en a une sur le beurre de pinottes rovia
l'histoire du beurre de pinottes pire
des séries une série sur deux trois
grands épisodes j'en ai enregistré 1 sur
les années 80 au québec donc politique
sociale culturelle une autre sur les
années 90 et 2000 pour faire une
rétrospective de tout ce qu'on a été un
peu comme ce que faisait musique plus là
je peux si vous aviez regardé y prenez
une année puis passer à travers
mais surtout de la musique mais moi je
fais surtout de l'histoire bien finie
quand même avec un peu de colle ou soit
vécu sa stricte sur des vidéos qui
traite de près ou de loin à la musique
est une bonne question je veux en faire
mais le grand défaut que j'ai c'est que
je suis pas musicien je ne sais pas
chanter
mon intérêt est très grand mais j'ai
tellement pas de passer à côté en tant
que mauvais musicien mais y'en a que je
veux faire par exemple jean faire une
sur jean sébastien bach une autre sur
henrie purcell qui sont deux des plus
grands musiciens dans ma tête mais pas
encore encore et ça s'en vient
cette indication
visés l'invité a été atteint à autre
chose c'est le balade aux fans
d'histoire c'est jean philippe wauthier
qui est venu justement balado lui qui a
parlé de
ça on peut regarder sur l'application
dit on sait aussi maintenant depuis hier
qu'ils défendent napoléon le qu'il était
en voyage qui est juste écouter des
passages sous napoléon déploie qu'elles
sont napoléon parlera de ses vacances
elle à la loi nome est un grand fan
danger les passes avec eux au départ
je le connais on devait faire un show
d'histoire
radio canut 15 puis radio canadiennes
ont finalement ça marchera mieux 15 ans
ouais ouais ouais puis ce qui est devenu
après c'est aujourd'hui l'histoire parce
qu'il pensait que les shows d'histoire à
l'epo marché des fois des fois un peu
drôle sopite et je reviens ce qui est ce
qu'on disait au début du podcast que tu
dit maintenant on a des idées du contenu
sur toutes les niches train
puis des tudip sportive certains ont
défendu leur peau dans leurs moindres -
des coups tout ce qui m'était fois le
team python épithètes en fin d'année un
exemple une excellente exemple ça ça
marche le tessin cet instant c'est
beaucoup de temps aux 6,1 s'est offert
son style est lancée sur mes qualités
quand vraiment est au dessus du prince
au au sérieux et puis autant dans la
dans le fond que dans la forme c'est
comme il ya vraiment un souci du détail
si on parlait des
photomatons contenu que dans le
contenant tu t'appliques c'est plus que
ça soit comme optimal
ce fait ce quelqu'un
pourrait faire on pourrait faire une
chaîne youtube de soli trottinette avec
la même passion et la même énergie la
même rigueur la même qualité que ça
fonctionnerait à fond de taux raison
piti moi ce que j'avais vu beaucoup
j'avais regardé beaucoup de sites auriel
sur comment faire une chaîne youtube une
toupie ou de celle qui m'avait marqué
c'était une fille de toronto qui
trichent sur sochaux devrait voir sa des
vidéos à 40 sur le marketing de youtube
et tout puis elle avait dit cette phrase
que je trouve très bonne a dit youtube
c'est pas un sprint c'est un marathon
si on revient aux thèmes qu'on disait si
tu penses que tu vas se carrer dans
suite dans la première année petit met
le doigt dans l'oeil du solide ça va
être long ça va être lourd serait
compliqué c'est la persévérance même man
et war des petites éclaircies qui vont
me donner envie de continuer mais comme
tu dis si bien dit faut qu'il soit
passionné par l'institut veut faire une
chaîne youtube pour être connu le
foot la peine que je compte tous les
jours on a aujourd'hui tous les jours
c'est même encore aujourd'hui qu'ils
vont en faire le successeur oui parce
que tu es mené ça fait 3 ans 3 mx est
gelée fondé en décembre 2010 est dit
what's next qu'est-ce que je peux faire
de différent plus les différences et des
longues séries mais ça me coûte
énormément physiquement puis en terme de
temps puis quand tu vois camani qui
plafonne c'est comme une entreprise
n'importe quoi se dit qu'est ce que je
peux faire de plus où est ce que je peux
aller puis je le sais pas dans réflexion
par rapport à tous c'est sûr que je vais
continuer mais quel angle je vais
adopter ce je ne sais pas mais celui qui
dit soi que je veux faso pour le reste
de ma vie je pense pas qu'une bonne et
il faut toujours aussi
passionnant qu'est ce qu'on fait
différent vers où on va commencer à
s'améliorer davantage que que tout c'est
que les sujets sont les sujets sont un
débat sans que la révolution française
ce
que je vais faire il veut que ce soit
toujours des sujets qui sont
indépendants du contexte dans lequel on
vit si l'histoire du beurre de pinottes
comme je te dis le fond on voit quand la
marge dans 50 approche je
l'entends viennent y en a une sur
l'histoire des gauchers comment ça se
fait que les gens ont associé la
gaucherie à quelque chose de mauvais
pittis c'est souvent pour un peu faire
une archéologie de notre quotidien pour
comprendre comment ça se fait qu'on ait
construit comme ça pis on peut
construire les manuels les choses de
manière différente mais à
chaque fois que je vois quelque chose
c'est pourquoi cette même des pics 1 qui
a inventé ça fait
ces enfants piemme année ça dit un peu
débilitant
merci infiniment et la mort merci
messieurs se jouera à
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le pétrole entre le pitch vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois c'est
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
une relance par mois et vous avez les
podcasts en avance xavier premier de
votre groupe d'amis avoir quitté les
podcasts qu'ils allaient avoir pouvoir
avoir une avance quand vous allez tirer
la dynamique entre les amys tout le
temps avons une avance sur l'étude joe
braun avance vous entre deux toits mais
avec pétillante une avance sur
l'humanité complète en plus en plus
parce que l'eau chez le podcast fini
voulu nous entendre jazzy davantage on
fait des encore moins de filtres à
préchac podcasts etc là on vient de
finir de tourner le podcast on vend
jaser on va t'il et nicole non nicolas
hulot maintenant et ayant comme un fils
travaille la place travot de taza taille
est là mais on jase on parle à condition
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pékin il faut s'abonner abonnez vous